thanks again dark my friends today the
January 6 committee put out a list of
people for whom they demand the private
records of and it includes tons of
prominent Trump supporters activists I
think it's what members of Congress even
right well I'm looking over and the
person nodding at me is one of the
people on the list getting uh getting
getting uh ready for that Gulag Jack I
am on the official regime enemies list
it is not the first time I have made a
regime enemies list I have so many
people I need to thank uh for for
allowing me this moment but but in all
seriousness
um
this represents a turning point right
this this has gotten and for me and for
my family you know I've had
conversations with
um you know with my wife who's actually
here tonight and and my parents you know
what what does this mean going forward
because here's the thing is this is a
first step they they this is the first
step this is overwhelmingly it's
Democrat and I don't think it's fair to
say republican because well you got like
kinsinger and Cheney yeah but it's like
it's establishment authoritarian they're
they're they're it's it's you it's Jack
I mean it's a huge list you've got Alex
Jones you've got Steve Ben you got Scott
Pressler uh Donald Trump his entire
family
um a huge slew of trump officials to
include cash Patel uh who if anyone has
seen plot against the president knows
what cash did behind the scenes so he's
been put on the list by the way to
neutralize him so that puts him in a
bind that he can't now go and operate
out
um you've got uh people that were part
of the administration people are in and
around the administration it's basically
if you are a public Trump supporter you
have now been put on this list and they
are now requesting and I say requesting
it is a subpoena for your private
Communications between April 2020 all
the way back April 2020. forward through
January we'll we'll definitely get into
all of the nitty-gritty details but
suffice it to say
wow man this is the biggest red flag it
is a 20-foot red flag raising you know
on top of a building this is not just
like uh Hey man things are oh that's
crazy I mean you know people want to
criticize me for saying things like
Civil War or balkanization the
government just targeted I mean some of
the names on this list are like
run-of-the-mill Twitter activists and
they're demanding the private details of
these people this is how it begins so we
got to talk about that we got to talk
about uh you know vaccine mandates and
and lockdown Stuff Plus what we may
maybe we'll bring up Australia a little
bit because they're doing those camps
um but I I we have a lot there's a lot
going on but I feel like this opening
story is just it's the biggest story of
maybe the past of Our Generation in fact
a list was put out by the US government
targeting political activists dissidents
uh it's freaky man but uh we're also
hanging out with uh Daniel down turner
oh you wanna Daniel Turner power of the
future um I think this is fifth time
back on the show it's great to be here
so thank you for having me on again you
guys went on a trip yeah to Alaska we
did yeah so we were like you know we
should have you guys come in and talk
about energy Independence and and
obviously uh what's been happening in
the US with Biden's policies and and
then the day you're supposed to come we
get this list drop Jack's on it and
we're like wow well so we'll get it yeah
that trumps a little bit trumps
you can't say Circle back now either no
oh yeah that's true yeah yeah it's
stolen but we'll get into all this stuff
uh for sure man this is this is heavy
stuff we got Ian is this confirmed it's
the government list because I'm seeing
it's from this dude this journalist put
this list out it's it's Kyle on the
January 6th committee yeah it's so is
this is the January 6th the select
committee the commission that they've
set up for the investigation into the
January 6 you know it was a riot at the
Capitol and they're now targeting and
keep in mind that the vast majority of
this the people on this list I and I
have to go check it again we're not
participants or members in any way
weren't there of what happened it's an
excuse me this is moving the chains this
is moving the chains
so we'll get into it so much there's so
much I am pushing buttons I'm going to
be super quiet today because I am really
ready to listen to what's going on with
this weird and crazy list and why Jack's
on it what did Jack do now before we get
into the apocalypse we do have a sponsor
who loves being a part of the show thank
you so much BioTrust because we talk
about really heavy things and you're uh
you're a great sponsor for the show go
to
eatrightandpeelwell.com to get your keto
Elevate MCT oil powder so if you want to
get better energy better mental Clarity
or you're doing the keto diet this
stuff's fantastic it is medium chain
triglyceride oil powder I'll tell you
what I do and actually Ian just did he
put in his coffee so good it's like
creamer almost you know so I mix it in
my coffee every day and it basically
acts like a creamer but it's it's almost
like a coconut oil I guess and it's got
all of this really great uh fat that
your body can use for energy and so uh
you'll get 51 off if you go to eat
rightandfeelwell.com they say it
increases Ketone levels inside your body
in turn supporting boost in metabolism
elevated energy and enhanced mental
focus when you go to EatRight and
feelwell.com you get a 60 day money back
guarantee they they say that uh keto
Elevate is very gentle on your stomach
five grams of the highly sought out
after mctc8 per scoop it is the most
advanced MCT powder on the market today
when you get you get free shipping on
every single order for every order today
BioTrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year plus you get free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order again
eatrightandfeelwell.com and I'll just
tell you I accidentally started doing
keto just because we did like a crab day
and I was eating nothing but like you
know fats and cheese and stuff I feel
absolutely fantastic cut the sugars out
Ian's always complaining about sugars
and I was like I'm just gonna go for it
because I was using this stuff just like
naturally and now I'm like you know what
I need to just just guzzle this stuff
putting all my coffee and my drinks and
again thanks BioTrust for being sponsors
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a bonus member
segment coming up as we do Monday
through Thursday if you're a member you
could ask to that and your support helps
fund our journalism and you'll also get
an ad-free experience but don't forget
to like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
now let's talk about the apocalypse
from CNBC
January 6 committee Demands a huge Trove
of trump White House Records burying the
lead here this is the official reporting
from CNBC but what they're not telling
you as much as the key point is the
house committee investigating January 6
assault in the capital formerly demanded
records related to at least 30 members
of former president Donald Trump's Inner
Circle
what they don't include in this is that
the list includes a ton of other people
we're talking like run-of-the-mill
activists we're talking about look
you've got Scott Pressler
why is Scott Pressler on this list for a
demand for records Scott Pressler is an
activist who registers Republicans to
vote and cleans up garbage
what does he have to do with January 6
you got Alex Jones oh and Shroyer
I don't even know some of these people
are do you guys know who Tracy Diaz is
no disrespect I don't know what that is
that's uh that's uh Tracy beans
oh on Twitter I don't know yeah I don't
even know I mean was was Tracy even
there I have no idea so all of these
names on this list these are the uh the
official demands they want all of these
names all look at this one they say they
want all documents and Communications
within the White House on January 6 2021
relating in any way to the following and
they say the January 6th rally the March
Donald J Trump Sarah Matthews hope Hicks
Mark Meadows Dan scavino Pat sip alone
Mark short Patrick Philbin Eric Hershman
Stephen Miller Greg Jacob I mean it's
it's everybody it's it's Trump's admin
you've got uh Kaylee mcinerney then you
go down I think the what's what's the
really the scariest thing about this is
when they start naming activists from
April 1st 2020 through January 20th 2021
all documents and Communications
concerning the 2020 election and
relating to the following individuals
and that's where we see you know Ali
Alexander Brandon strzok Rose tenant
Vernon Jones Michael Flynn Alex Jones oh
and Shroyer Scott Pressler Jack passobic
Angela Stanton King George Papadopoulos
Mark Burns Roger Stone George Flynn I
mean the I don't even know Enrique tario
Michael kodri I don't even know who some
of these people are but these are not
politicians Katrina Pearson who so who
was that that she was the spokesman for
the Trump campaign in 2016 Chief
spokesman and were these people there no
why do they want Communications here
before which and keep in mind what it
says what it says and and my my legal
team has been over this with a
fine-tooth comb what they're requesting
for if you look at this specific
subsection where it names you know kind
of the activists it doesn't even mention
the actual January 6 event itself it
just says all documents and
Communications concerning the 2020
election from April to January 20th so
essentially if you had any comment
whatsoever any communication whatsoever
with uh with the government from that
entire it's almost a year that they're
asking for of the private records
personal Communications that they are
trying to subpoena this has nothing to
do with January 6. they'll tell you very
quickly what they're trying to do with
me and I'm exactly what they're trying
to do with me is they are trying to go
after my White House sources they want
to know who it is that I've been in
communication with at the White House
that of course is being done in a way
where I'm keeping them private they're
giving me information it's a network of
people that send stuff to me and then I
get it out right they know that this has
been a thorn in the side of the body
administration because there are some
people that are even in the Biden
Administration that are looking at this
they want to get into my records and
they want to get that out well I'm here
to say right now to Nancy Pelosi and
anybody else you're not getting it
you're not getting my sources you can
send whatever you want to me you can do
whatever you want to me I'm not giving
it up because these people are patriots
they are telling me the truth they're
telling me the truth about what's going
on when it comes to covid and the
government's response they're telling me
the truth about what's going on in the
ground in Kabul they're telling me the
truth about what's actually going on
behind the scenes at the White House as
opposed to the lies that you people are
putting out in your press briefings and
and so if you want to come for it you
better be ready this is a this is
absolutely better be ready and your
stand is admirable and they're going to
come after you and I I and you're a hero
for standing up to them this this is a
two-fold in my opinion a process the
first is to punish those people who are
on the wrong side
um this is to punish them you
specifically the people on this list
this is the scary part of using
political powers to punish your enemies
but the second part also is to send a
warning for people in the future don't
join the wrong side because this is
what's going to happen to you this is
meant to silence and scare people who
want to get politically active the only
reason why I didn't go January 6th is
because like I had something on the farm
it was a two-hour Drive I think it was
cold and rainy and I kind of actually
felt bad I was like you know what I
should be there there's like 40 000
people but like I just like I can't make
it I just I honestly couldn't make it
and it was like ah I can't but what if
you know how many people uh would have
made the same decision and that is to
say to people like me next time there's
a rally I like this don't go Daniel
because you look look what they'll do to
you oh and Shroyer just got charged he
was released I guess he can't talk about
it but so so the way this works is
they're they're making a demand for
internal government documentation on
these individuals that's correct Jack
right so what it is is this is the first
step in the process what they're doing
now is they're going for internal
government documents that would have
been held under the Trump Administration
as pertains to the presidential records
act as well as anything else that might
be on file regarding this
um you know the uh regarding the
election at least there's different
subsections and there's different types
of things that they're asking for for
different groups of people and so but by
and large it's a letter to the National
archivist so what that is is all those
records so when you go to a presidential
museum and you'll see that they have the
entire records of that Administration
there if you go to you know the candy
Museum or the Roosevelt museum and so
what they've done now obviously Trump
doesn't have a museum yet up um Obama
doesn't even have his Museum up yet he's
against some uh legal trouble with that
but what they do is they the national
archivist will set all of those records
aside
so then the question becomes does and
Will trump uh come back and I think they
know what's going to happen is that
he'll exert what's called executive
privilege over either all of these
records or a portion of these records
and then of course that's where the
politics comes in and they're going to
demand well hey these people were
outside the administration like myself I
wasn't a member of the administration I
was working for one American News at the
time
um who I actually did have a phone call
with today and and we you know we talked
about everything and we said and they
said you know we got your back Jack now
I have a trivia question for you if you
wanted to avoid the presidential records
Act
and you set up a separate email server
would you put that service basement
basement bathroom right the basement
bathroom
exactly so this is what that's how you
bypass it great way yeah explaining this
you set up
jackpocworld.com and you have everyone
and I am Steve Johnson and Jack bishopa
and we all use this and it's run out of
my basement and that way when the big
Power of foia comes in and says we want
to see your records you say I'm not
using any government to be fair I'm
using but come on
that was the whole purpose of it to
avoid this process Daniel we have to
fact check you okay this is fake news
she was just she had those emails were
yoga that was yoga her daughter's
wedding I guess she's not doing the yoga
that much see we all understand yeah
exactly exactly yeah Hillary was just
talking about yoga
10 plus thousand thirty thousand thirty
thousand emails about her daughter's
server to avoid government exactly for
this exactly exactly for this purpose
because when an activist uh partisan
group gets together and they decide that
they want to expand and it's a complete
overreach a massive overreach of
political capital and government Capital
where they want to go into people's
private lives like this this is one way
that if you are somebody like Hillary
Clinton who's running these off the
books operations we saw that what city
Blumenthal was running around Libya
right before the invasion and all of
this right that she's able to do that
mixing classified information in and out
but if you're someone you know and
that's totally fine when you're Hillary
Clinton but if you're someone in the
Trump Administration right like imagine
if you know Donald Trump had a private
email another guy doesn't use email but
you know we know it would happen this is
what happens when you're on the other
side of that they will come after you
with the full force of the federal
government and what I've been told what
I've been told from a lot of people is
okay that's the presidential records act
this is just step one yeah well well
Jack this is not going to end at this
have you given any thought to what job
you'll be doing in the gulag yes
um yes as a matter of fact I have so I
have already picked out my Gulag job and
you know it's it's already taken and but
it's actually going to be providing a
service to everyone else you know who's
on the list and probably everyone in
this room will be there with me
um especially Ian yeah well he's he'll
be the graphene Jack he'll be playing
bass and so I'll be playing bass yeah no
so I'm going to be providing the
Mandarin lessons for everybody so we'll
I'll be able to teach you up in Mandarin
will be to learn learn very quickly
we'll you know we'll try to get
characters I know with some Daniel you
know you might be in the remedial class
yeah that's fine that way I'll be
working for Nike I'll be making that
exactly yes you'll be very happy right
and and that way we'll be able to
communicate with the guard so it'll
actually quite useful for us that's good
planning ahead Jack that's great yeah
how do you say sounds effing awesome in
Manchester
all right all right
you know we let we joke about this stuff
but uh
this is not this list clearly is not
about January 6th no no it's it's
calling for records but related to the
election what they've what they've what
they want to do what they've been trying
to do which every step of the way has
been
uh they've just literally gutted and
mutilated the American Republic from the
first impeachment to the second
impeachment to the constant harassment
to the lies in the media they hated
Trump so much that they were willing to
do anything and by the way it's not done
though so we're doing lists now do you
uh I'll just say this right now every
step of the way since going back to 2017
2018 I've been talking about some kind
of civil conflict Civil War I've said I
see no reason for this to de-escalate
now I would I have no problem saying
right now for all I know everything just
slows down people finally say I'm done
with the conflict I don't want to be
fighting anymore and everyone shakes
hands and we and we move along all of a
sudden Republicans Democrats hugging in
the hallways but I don't see any reason
for that to happen no then not only do
we have a shootout last weekend in
Portland between left and right-wing
groups you now have predominantly
Democrats let's be real kinzinger and
Cheney are not anything other than
Democrats with a republican for a name
they're coming out and saying we want to
know about the election we want to know
about what their strategies were their
campaigns we want to know what the what
the Trump Administration any of these
people and the government were talking
with these people about Scott Pressler
the guy who cleaned up garbage in
Baltimore and you know here's what's
going to happen here's the first step is
the list right the next step is they you
say they won't get it they're not going
to get the they're not going to get that
information right here's my prediction
that could be wrong but here's just a
thought I had maybe maybe it's a long
shot
they'll say okay well how about we have
the archivist start checking to make
sure those records exist and then if
they're gonna you know and then the
judge will be like well before they can
be released there has to be a challenge
and there's an injunction
then they leak and then private
Communications start leaking out of
context all of a sudden news stories
emerge accusing people of very serious
wrongdoing and it's used to cede very
very bad press and and shot content
through the midterms and into the next
presidential election and how they'll do
this also and this is just how the
justice department works when it's
pursuing a lead is they will say all
right well this is only official
government correspondence so any.gov
whitehouse.gov email address that
mentions Jack by name and then they'll
read the email and they'll say Jack was
at the Christmas party on Thursday and
they'll say well we need to know more
about their Christmas party and who else
was at the Christmas party Lydia was at
that Christmas party well now we need
Lydia's records because Lydia is now
tied to Jack because and it will just
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
then all of a sudden now you're turning
over things that aren't whitehouse.gov
now you are turning over private stuff
and it's like look you know we went to
the D.A and there's enough evidence here
that yeah we have to keep digging you
keep digging and eventually all of us
are guilty of some what's that book
crime of day we're all guilty of like
four crimes a day they'll go to a grand
jury a non-adversarial court they'll say
look at this these people are implicated
in January 6 for this reason and the
grand jury is going to be like do it
indictment right and they're gonna go
and then they'll go to uh even prior to
that but they'll go to what Comcast
Verizon
Etc and they're going to say hey we're
you know we're investigating this it's
very important we need these records we
need to go through all this so you know
turn it all over and of course they will
like I'm under no
uh I want to know aspersions that they
what they want to do what they're trying
to do here is remember George
Papadopoulos the fact that he's on this
list as well he was caught up in this he
got a date wrong right he got a date
wrong in the first one of these witch
hunts during rushgate so he got the date
wrong in russiagate and so he went to
jail for a week because when he sat down
and had that conversation he couldn't
remember when he met the guy who talked
about Hillary's emails you know I said
it was this day it was actually a month
before you know
um you know a year later right that's
how they get you that's what they're
looking for is perjury that's why Trump
refused to go in person and said he'd
have to draft a letter written only
right so my lawyers are preparing a
number of of methods to to prevent any
of this but if they if they do try to
subpoena in me and ask me to go for any
of my sources um that's that's the hard
line I will not give you anything in
regards to that in fact I'm not going to
comply with any of these requests if I
have any choice in the matter whatsoever
I'm not going to comply I'm not going to
have anything to do with this I'm not
going to listen to what you say look I
spent a year at Guantanamo Bay already
send me back I don't care send me to
gitmo I've been there already you
weren't there as a prisoner yeah you
have to phrase that properly I don't
care not much difference honestly not
much difference between I've been on one
side of the class I'll be on the other
side of the glass I don't care I want to
Lydia pull up this uh this graphic yeah
this is an image that we've seen before
on the show and we debated uh whether or
not it was true and correct but it's the
10 stages of genocide now the first
thing is that this graphic we have is an
oversimplification of the actual 10
stages of genocide uh that was initially
written I think it was written by a
historian or academic talking about what
we see through various authoritarian
dictatorships but let me just read some
for you they said the first stage is
classification people are divided into
Us and Them
to stage two is symbolization people are
forced to identify themselves three
discrimination people begin to face
systematic discrimination four is
dehumanization people equated with
animals Vermin or diseases five is
organization the government creates
specific groups police and military to
enforce the policies six is polarization
the government broadcasts propaganda to
turn the populace against the group
seven is preparation official action to
remove and relocate people eight is
persecution the beginning of murders
theft of property trial massacres nine
is extermination wholesale elimination
of the group and 10 is denial the
government denies that it committed any
crime now
I don't think that this is a linear uh
path you know I think it's just several
things you see in uh genocide or or uh
you know dictatorship so I'll just very
quickly say
well the last time we talked about this
we we got to uh number two people are
forced to identify themselves and it's
like where are people being forced to
identify themselves yeah not Australian
political political uh or uh gender you
know
the conversation we're having before was
about you know the obviously you know
January 6th they put out this list of a
bunch of people including trab activists
but when you think about it in terms of
the vaccine oh this list is
is scary I mean for one Us and Them oh
yeah they keep going on TV saying that
all of this is the fault of people who
aren't vaccinated people are forced to
identify themselves yes they're
mandating that you Reveal Your
identification at buildings people are
facing systematic discrimination you
can't go into buildings people are
equated with equated with animals Vermin
or diseases horse medicine they're
talking about people who are taking
Ivermectin not FDA approved for for use
in covid mind you but they're equating
it with with animal the government
creates specific groups police and
military to enforce the policies are we
there yet is that happening is there a
specific group that's been created for
this
while the Capitol Police has been
expanded but that's that's more Maga
stuff that's not vaccine related stuff
they say the government broadcasts
propaganda well I mean fauci won't shut
up and then official action to remove
and relocate people I'll tell you this I
don't think we're there yet in terms of
the vaccine but you have various aspects
of this across the board we got to be
careful we don't play into this either
because the first one Us and Them I've
noticed when I have conversations here
and in general I talk about them like
they are the Biden crew or whatever the
Deep State whatever they I'm feeding
this and if I keep talking lazily acting
like that they're going to keep acting
like see I just did it again they
there's no they it's us we are humans on
Earth together Ian that's that's that's
that's utopian thing well but if it's if
we don't go that direction we're going
to start dividing people that's like
saying it's very easy I don't need
someone who's thinking that those terms
they you know that you know and you hear
this by the way what you just said is if
you turn on tune into MSNBC or CNN right
now and listen to how they talk about
these medical mandates they always use
terms of we and us we need to do this we
need to do that right we this is It's
always we it's always we need to make
things harder for them
and who is we and look at the way they
talk about we were you what was the what
was the adjective we kept using in
Alaska when they talked about the crowd
who was at Obama's birthday party how
they described sophisticated we are
sophisticated we're a sophisticated
vaccinated class right that's why there
was no concern about that party it was a
sophistic we are the enlightened ones
we're the Smart Ones we are you you know
Bill Maher made this uh a five six well
maybe it was about a year and a half ago
on one of his monologues where we talked
about Middle America right we have
Wolfgang Puck they have Chef Boyardee
right right we have this they have that
they're envious of us so I I appreciate
what you're saying from the humanitarian
perspective I wish we were a Wii but I
fear that if I don't have a they versus
us they're gonna kill me like they talk
about me
you know what they're doing to you with
this with this uh January 6 commission
right now
they have complete desire to eradicate
me from the political space from the the
discourse space from the what I do for a
living and so if I don't put up
boundaries they're coming out and
remember what we've also seen that's
going on and this is something where
that I'm going to get into if they want
to pursue this with me is they will set
up operations and we've seen this in the
past we've seen this even just last year
where the federal government and the FBI
will use a system of informants and
plants that will go into various grooves
these sort of like Edge case groups
Discord chats Facebook groups and then
they will become accelerants so they
will accelerate what's going on they
will become accelerationists for that
particip that specific unit that
specific group of people whether it's a
militia or something and we are going to
get unto all of that Nancy Pelosi I want
to find Nancy Pelosi's personal
Communications that were members of
these militias I want to go after all
the communications that her and her
staff have had with Stuart Rhodes
I want to make a point to wrap up what
Ian said
the there's only one thing you need to
understand to understand uh so you know
that this this is just not correct go
tell the Taliban what you just said go
walk up to them outside of the the
airport in Kabul and say we're all in
this together there's no Us in them and
see how they treat you well sometimes it
works no I've been in situations where I
don't even speak the language but as
long as you Vibe with them you are one
of them you're gonna Vibe with the
Taliban I don't know you could they're
walking around with guns they're they're
they're they're beating people in the
streets that's kind of a fantasy because
I don't know them I've never seen a
person that identifies as Taliban or all
I've seen is propaganda I I've I've met
Taliban I think going to what you're
saying their Vibe is how much of the
Quran do you have memorized their their
Vibe is you know do you perform zakat
are you praying five times a day
um and you're an American it doesn't
matter
have you submitted to Islam right it it
right yes and no but it it doesn't
matter and if you're an American right
now then you're immediate like yeah
that right that Australian guy there's
an Australian guy just mind walking to
the airport and they just started
beating him why would they do that I
know but they're it's just us right I
see partly what you're saying because
there are situations where it can become
so volatile that if you insert yourself
you'll be destroyed without in a moment
but what do you think is happening we
can also create that volatility
this is part of that creating that
volatility if we we can also create that
volatility if we want so it's like
you can acknowledge that it's there
without propelling it ignoring the
problem won't make itself
put it this way as as you know as a as a
Catholic I I believe that you know that
there is a heaven and in in that
wonderful you know the new Eden the New
Kingdom that there it will be us and we
will all be one and we'll all be
together but uh in this current moment
in this part of the movie that we're in
right now in what we're living through
what I'm personally living through when
I look at my kids when I put them to bed
and think is this the last time I'm
going to see them because somebody's
going to come knock on my door and take
me away with CNN with CNN getting tipped
off because of my opinions
right I don't really have that luxury
right now but I do have the I do have my
rosary and I say that every day that's
all I got you raised an interesting
point I think this is where our system
is rigged and it is very messed up and
that you said I'd love to see Nancy
Pelosi's correspondence but but Congress
is exempt right Congress doesn't have to
share their records no one has the
authority to ask for Nancy Pelosi's
records now she has the authority to ask
for the president's records
um I find that the a huge flaw with our
problem right foia does not exist in the
judicial and the uh excuse me in the
legislative branch you can ask your your
Senator I'll get him well if someone
leaks them I'll get them but but my
point is that you don't have the the she
has she does she doesn't know how far my
network goes that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying that that legally [ __ ] yes
you don't right we don't and not
everyone is Jack pesobic but Daniel
these are better men that's not what
they're so sophisticated that they are
sufficient they're so sophisticated
they're so much better that is a huge
problem with the way that with the way
things are structured right now
um and and so you can subpoena you you
can impeach the president twice but what
Authority does the president have to say
I would like to know how Nancy Pelosi is
coordinating with X Y or Z to come after
me and my admissions on the Belt fed uh
the crew served machine oh and another
one by the way Chuck Schumer did you see
what happened to your boy Andrew your
boy Andrew Cuomo he's not really smart
boy she's saying that because I'm from
New York you saw that right away right
yeah I know some things Andrew or I know
some things Chuck
don't don't go there don't go there
they're going there
okay Chuck you know you know what's
funny is uh when you look over in
Australia we got uh they're building
camps you know what I saw what's really
funny check this out check this out um
you see they have the QR codes as well
on the doors they're putting signs on
people's doors suspected of having
coveted now here's the best so you have
to swipe in it's it's grocery stores
it's it's where you when you go to work
if you're going uh I don't know if
churches are open this and now I think
this is mainly the New South Wales it's
that one area where it's where it's
works it is it is uh
it's a Minority Report man
you know what I saw today I looked at
this article from nine news Australia of
they have an interactive map of all of
the areas of New South Wales that are
under lockdown surprise surprise it's
all of them and stay-at-home orders
you're only allowed to leave for very
specific things but Chris Hemsworth
we're not surfing you know why because
if you're rich you're exempt wow
absolutely and there's been people
complaining about it saying how come the
rich people are at the beach and they
said shut your mouth peasant do you
think anyone's gonna arrest Crimson
Chris Hemsworth he's a national icon
he's a treasure he's Exempted just like
our politicians are exempt from all of
our code no I want to make sure this is
clear I think Chris Hemsworth's red I
don't blame him for this the government
every is is is is implementing I'll put
it this way I don't think it's the fault
of Chris Hemsworth that he's successful
and able to go to the beach nope I think
what that really means is the government
is purposefully punishing the poor they
are purposefully beating down poor
people yeah that's the problem when you
see the churches that they were going
after no you know I saw this video and
uh it's amazing because I looked up the
Anchor's name because the guy tweeted
out with some like a local news thing in
Australia and the guy's name was
actually Peter Overton his name is
actually Overton wow simulation right
and and there and then they go and they
interview somebody and he said and it's
this it's this like you know pasty white
guy with a mask going well I just I just
had to call the police on this church
and what they were doing was just so
wrong and it was terrible he's looking
at the vocal fry you know and and you
and you look at the church and these are
like
um uh the majority of them appear to be
immigrants uh to Australia and they ver
not well all in this like folding chairs
and like not well off church but it was
a place where people were going because
they were looking for some semblance of
connect action to the Eternal and to the
infinite something positive a sense of
community where they could get over and
because one and you should hear the way
I don't know if you have the you know
the clip or of it but the way they're
talking about this church they call them
arrogant and they call them greedy and
self-interested and I'm like these these
are Christians you're referring to this
way people who are not affluent people
who aren't on fancy news networks like
Peter Overton you you raised a great
point of of how you know it is punishing
the poor and when Obama had his birthday
party a couple weeks ago and people were
saying you know hypocrisy Etc I took a
very different approach and another
thing that happened to the birthday
party John Kerry showed up in his
private jet right and people said shame
on John Kerry hypocrisy and I said if I
had John Kerry's wealth and married a
rich widow
um the old-fashioned way you make your
money right I would fly a private jet
and if I had Obama's wealth and Prestige
I would have a party with 600 of my
closest friends the point is not that
they did it everyone should have that
right the point is that the people
telling us us to go green and to lock
down are never going to do it right they
are never going to follow the laws that
they want the powerless the voiceless
the nameless and faceless stuff well
keep in mind that is the problem what
they're doing about the hypocrisy it's
that you don't have the power to thwart
the laws that the rest of us are
imposing on what the green movement has
wanted for a generation
the same people are now getting through
the threat of covet covet Envy is a real
thing right so they they wish that they
could get right you know so now it's all
the people who were you know like sort
of like the grifter class the ones that
are just pushing the stuff that you know
they used to be climatologists now
they're all epidemiologists you know
they they went to bed one night and woke
up and now they're they're getting the
restrictions they are getting the
mandates they're getting everything they
wanted to take away people's Liberties
and people's freedoms through the threat
of it's you know it's it's almost cliche
to say it at this point but the Rahm
emanuel's famous quote never let a
crisis go to waste yeah and covid is for
your good for the good of society
therefore you have to follow these
prescriptions and the environmentalists
have wanted that forever that covid shut
down people's ability to go to church
right the Australia laws which are that
list that you mentioned which came out
today was you read that and it reads
like uh uh uh Nazis Nazis they're Nazis
people of Australia
I mean they're protesting they are but
you have and it's going to get literal
when I say literal I'm saying thousand
dollar fines if they catch you outside
and at what point do the police the
Australian police who I hope are
listening to this podcast on Horseback
say I am not going to hit this person
with my but you see the video well did
you see the hitting the truckers videos
at what point did the Australian police
say I am not obeying this order I saw
you know and it was I saw a couple of
videos where it was trucker saying you
know we we run this country and people
realize so we look on the map Australia
is pretty big but it's if you look at
the actual
um you know I always do map breaks on on
Twitter if you look at the actual
populated areas it's only around the
coast right it's very sparsely populated
and so those truckers that are
absolutely necessary as much as they are
everywhere else but really in Australia
when they're shipping those goods when
they're shipping that food and you see
you're starting now to hear these
truckers and they say they're saying we
will shut this country down over this if
you keep pushing us over this but will
enough we will stop well that's a
question isn't it you know because we we
like to talk about the police and you
know we with a big move into abolish
police this is why I'm saying right now
I've I've been on the abolish the police
train for a little bit most of talking
to Michael malice and it has a lot to do
with watching what happened with the
lockdowns how many cops not all of them
you know NYPD I think a lot of people on
the right
had had a moment they went through
something watching those videos yeah but
they're going right back to back to Blue
you know there's a period where we saw
people on the right throwing police the
The Thin Blue Line flag on the ground
and stomping on it because the cops were
now turning on them but you look at
what's happening in Australia and who's
enforcing it's all these Metro cops and
they're they're they're Mason little
girls it is some of the most insane yeah
for the protect them
they're busting down doors and taking
people out of their homes they're
shutting down churches in New York City
they shut down churches you I'm telling
you right now you've got you've got a
slight opportunity or you had it's
probably gone when the left kept saying
defund and abolish if every conservative
said you got it then you would avoid
what's coming next I mean the issue
there is you have a psychological uh
difference of a Viewpoint when it comes
to it so the right one of the uh leading
planks of the right is is wanting an
ordered Society right so this idea of of
being conservative means that you want
that traditional ordered society and so
rule of law and the enforcement
mechanism the forcing function for rule
of law would be a lawful and uh
dignified Police Service of course and
that's the idea versus what is that
what's happening and that's not what's
happening right but what I'm saying is
is you to get a conservative to kind of
go wholeheartedly and join hands with
like a BLM member on that you it would
take a lot of conversation and a lot of
looking at issues like what you're
talking about by the way and getting
them to actually sit down and say wait a
minute perhaps there were and I actually
had
uh Nico house who's a a BLM guy he's
like Amanda left but he's someone that
I've become friends with and someone
that I talk to and one thing that he
always says is Jack I I'm not against
the rule of law what I'm against is
corruption right and aren't you against
corruption I say well yeah of course I'm
against corruption well then maybe we're
not as in disagreement as it seems yeah
the enforcement mechanism I don't think
is the problem I think that the problem
is uh these leaders who have Newfound
powers that no one is stopping
absolutely I agree with you that the
police should not be enforcing bad laws
plus by the way like this when you
demonize the police
step two cops leave and Scrubs come true
I am ordering all churches to shut and
and so it takes and it takes courage
people to say I'm just not listening to
that now steps
the cops are are playing their role I
agree with you but Step One is when the
when the mayor says as of today no
church is allowed to be open you know
you need priests and and ministers and
parishioners to say it's nice
I don't think it's an excuse though
we hear all the time right now there's a
mandate New York City if you are if you
are disabled sick or unable to get the
vaccine or for a religious reason it is
not the police stopping you it is the
mom and pop restaurants and bakery
saying F you get out of my store I don't
care I was told to do it so I will if
all of these people in New York said I
will not abide by illegal activities
because violating uh discriminating at
someone on the base of a disability is a
violation of New York City state and
federal health uh and non-discrimination
laws they'll do it anyway because they
don't care they're feckless spineless
pathetic losers they all do it and each
and every one of these police officers
has a choice they can be a villain when
when when you want to be a henchman to
the villain by all means that's your
choice no one forces these people to be
henchmen but if the cops want to come
out and say yeah I don't care if it's
unconstitutional I don't care if it
violates my oath to the Constitution I'm
gonna beat that old lady so she can't go
to church church it's not Cuomo who did
it it's that individual police officer I
agree with you and they're and they're
doing it to restaurants they're doing it
to salons they're letting prisoners go
and locking up small business owners
this is
exactly and you see what's happening in
Australia
we are we are we are a few months behind
where they've been now we have a
Constitution which does provide us some
shielding on this but if police officers
have already been willing to arrest and
fine and and and uh block people from
going to church it's it's the first
amendment so it is the rule of don't
care it is the role of individuals
individual police officers and
individual ministers
uh priests Parish priests and
individuals or restaurant owners and and
bar owners it is the role of the
individual to say I am not following
this when you say abolish the police we
are talking about institutions and I
would argue that the institution is not
the thing at flaw right now so I I
disagree with the abolish the police
movement because we are talking about
institutional flaws you're absolutely
right if there is a cop who was told by
the sergeant hey you got to go to arrest
that person because they're trying to
get into the bar and they do it every
time well then and that's a huge problem
absolutely and then enough cops are
eventually going to say I'm not doing it
but teachers are already quitting their
jobs I'm just following that as Jack
just mentioned it's an individual
problem the cops who won't do it quit
and we've seen that and I've got an
email after email and it's and it's
what do we see in Seattle we saw the
cops apologizing to antifa as they
arrested the victim of antiva violence
crazy I can sum all this up for anyone
who you hasn't um you've gotten there
yet get out of cities
just get get out of cities just don't be
there right I I was joking with uh
Michael Knowles that he had that you
know reason to vote for Democrats book
and it's all blank on the inside
and that uh I was like I should pull it
take a page out of your book and do a
get out of Cities book and then just
have one page get out of cities the next
page just don't be there just don't be
there and then you know 300 pages of
that which you know Survival Guide for
the survival guide don't don't be there
and and if people say what do what
exactly do you mean by that Jack and
they want to drill down and you know
kind of get get into it I said get out
of city but we do have institutional
problems um these institutions
they're absolutely broken where is the
ACLU right where is the that was an
institution where is I would argue as
well where is the Catholic Church to say
sorry we're not closing our doors I
think the problem is we're just there
are institutional failures we're in a
pandemic whatever you think about the
kovid whatever but we're in officially a
pandemic I think so we're acting like
habeas corpus is suspended like Spanish
Flu time like martial law like we're
basically under martial law right now I
don't think they've officially declared
it but that's how it and we've suspended
Corpus before in this country
and it didn't go very well like Lincoln
did it during and people would say well
we won right but but
when you have Eugene dubs when when you
have small businesses locked up Japanese
in World War World War II yeah and you
have small business owners being
arrested while prisoners are being freed
and far leftists went around causing
billions in Damages in big and small
cities across this country it's not
suspension of habeas corpus it's a
narco-tyranny and the police are more
than happy I will tell you this
we we already see the stories of the
sheriff in Minnesota who arrested that
woman because she had a cafe and she
refused to shut down if you purchase a
weapon as is your second Amendment right
to protect yourself as riots are going
on I guarantee you these police will go
to your house and they will arrest you
you mean like our writtenhouse
absolutely if you are concerned that a
70 year old man was bashed over the
health with a rock and left bleeding on
the ground which happened in Kenosha and
you say I'm scared for my community and
then someone comes and says how would
you you're a young man work at the YMCA
how would you like to help protect our
business as you say okay and then when a
man chases you trying to steal your gun
you flee and then when someone else
fires a gun at you from behind you turn
and when that man reaches for your gun
you fire in defense they will lock you
up they will go to your house in
Wisconsin black lives matter and when
you brandish a firearm to show that
you're acting in defense of your home
the police will go into your house and
arrest you and black lives matter will
celebrate it they did when black lives
matter went to a house in in Milwaukee
and set fire to it because they thought
two girls were kidnapped there and they
weren't this is why a guy in his house
sees the same group and was the same
group same activists and thanks I better
you know let them know I'm armed now he
shouldn't have pointed the weapon at
them that I can I can say but black
lives matter they were the ones who were
complaining about the cops but when the
cops showed up they celebrated it and
the cops didn't stop the writers what
did I say a year before this when we
were when we were still living in
Philadelphia
and we were looking at the riots I said
I tell you this there will come a time
when the rioters when the mob when the
cultists the fascists whatever come to
your house and are protesting and the
police will show because of a
disturbance in the neighborhood and
they'll look at each other and say
what's easier arresting the guy in the
house or dealing with a riot just the
rest of the guy in the house and they've
done it
yeah keeping the peace they don't care
about your rights so I look at right now
when we see a lot of these cops quitting
after the default the police stuff I
tell you this man the videos we see now
like the one in Seattle antifa is
chasing a guy he's backing up and he's
saying get away from me and the cops
come and arrest him and then say I'm so
sorry ma'am would you mind and to antifa
I think extremists I think though
to only blame cops and to single out
cops solely right is is maybe a little
bit you know limiting in terms of how
you're looking at it right we are
looking at in our cities a symptom a
symptom of a broader societal collapse
of moral values of national institutions
well I'm not just general identity no I
don't think you are but I think a lot I
think there are a lot of people are who
do that
um and I think that a lot of what we're
what we're seeing now is the collapse of
this very a lot of this started in the
60s you can argue it went back further
but when it really comes down to it if
we do not have a national shared vision
of what our morals are what are our
national identity is what does it mean
to be American when we're starting to
destabilize these societies like these
groups like anti I just heard a whole
book about antifa but and I pointed out
their their role is not like they have
their stated role but then they have
their actual in practice role they
destabilize systems right we saw this in
Weimar Germany where was the that was
the original institution of antifa right
they were a red front group the idea was
destabilize the country and then
somebody sweeps in and then someone
takes power but who are the ones
attacking the shared vision of what
makes the country who are the one
attacking the shared values and that's
why again going back to your point and I
and I truly mean this
I like the fact that you want to be a we
I want to be a Wii wouldn't it be great
when I look at our we institutions you
take something as simple as
this is a minute and a half of your time
that we're going to say the darn
national anthem and you sing it and
you're going to be quiet
and and for this minute and a half
whether you like it don't like it you
think it's stupid this minute and a half
is not your minute it is it's the
national anthems minute and we're all
gonna shut the hell up just like at your
wedding when someone was when you were
doing your vows if I stood up and was
like you know I want to make a comment
right now people will be like whoa whoa
whoa this is Jack and Tanya's wedding
this is why we didn't invite them
exactly almost this is not your time the
national anthem is not your this belongs
to the country shut the hell up you know
I want to protest you got the whole
world to protest but this belongs to the
shared values of the country but you
can't have it what do you do now it has
to now it's destroyed if this flag you
can't have it this image can't have it
there are no more shared images because
we are told
let me throw this out there's a lot of
programs to kind of put put a pin on
that is what and what you were saying
earlier Ian what do you think would
happen if you went to Afghanistan right
now and tried to set a Taliban flag on
fire
you probably get gunned what do you
think would happen if you went out there
and you saw you know a a you know a
Taliban
uh you know sure council meeting and you
walked up and started protesting what do
you think what do you think would happen
if when the after the Taliban took over
you took the Afghan national flag and
started carrying it through the streets
oh wait that did happen people were
brutally beaten what happens when you
when you when you knock down a pride
flag the hate police in New York I think
it's in Queens are they hate police is
out because it's on camera someone
knocked down a pride flag
we have to you're not allowed to do that
we have sporting events doing two
national anthems now
okay why not three I'm not into the
symbolism thing like if if Xi Jinping
commanded us to sing the national anthem
it wouldn't be well you will American
prize
don't step on my freedom no it'll it'll
be you can't make if Xi Jinping makes me
say I love America it doesn't mean I
really love America no one's asking you
to say you love America they are asking
for this one particular moment this
thing does not belong to you and it is
humbling for all of us and the
collective values of this country to say
you know what that's not mine just like
those vows that moment your speech you
know what it's it's Ian's birthday ding
ding ding and Ian wants that no no no
I'm gonna stop and this this is also
this is my what this is one moment in
time that does not belong to any
individual but no individual can usurp
it and there's got to be something that
unites a community so that when it comes
to conflict they say we may disagree on
X Y and Z but because of the overarching
umbrella we are here for each other
America used to be they would talk about
diversity the great Melting Pot but
American culture and values always
superseded so when people talk about
multiculturalism there's two definitions
the left definition well I should say
the the original view of
multiculturalism was you can come and
have Chinatown you can have Ukrainian
Village Little Italy little Russia
whatever but you followed the rules and
the overarching culture of America and
you know what people liked that that's
what they wanted to be here but maybe
they spoke Ukrainian and wanted to live
by their relatives but they still were
free speech they still were Second
Amendment they still wanted to uh you
know live in this great country what
started happening now is that
Multicultural multiculturalism has come
to mean something different that there
are Pockets that exist outside of
Americans values and cultures when those
start growing a completely separate
moral framework there is nothing uniting
two groups you end up with two national
anthems within the same space and I'll
tell you this two objects cannot occupy
the same space so when you have people
who are under an umbrella all saying
okay you know I like skateboarding you
like BMX and he likes snowboarding but
we're all Americans we believe in free
speech and we like watching you know
Michael Jackson music videos or
something that unites us we don't have
that anymore now you have people who say
all of your movies are racist and bad
and you're not allowed to like them
anymore we're going to sing a different
national anthem okay you have a
completely different world view a
completely different moral framework and
these things struggle to coexist with
each other that's the that's that's the
thing about the national anthem I don't
think it's necessarily that we like
force people to undergo it but it's it's
more a sign that when we come to a point
where we cannot agree the national
anthem is something that we'll listen to
and like and we're proud of that half
the people are like play a different one
now in one Arena people are are fighting
a symbolic or ideological war when they
say they're gonna do two national
anthems well it's also you know I mean
you think of it right any sporting event
is already two teams and two groups of
fans that are there in opposition right
they're there to I want to defeat you
you want to defeat me like I'm from
Philadelphia so you know whenever you
know whenever we're playing you know
where the Giants are in town you know it
got pretty rough like we literally had a
I almost was attacked in a sports game
yeah we literally evolved we were
screaming for the Browns yeah exactly
but yeah but Philly fans are the most
awful people silly Eagles fans no
offense to Philadelphia but they were
actually quite proud
yeah
we have we had an actual trial before we
had an actual trial court that would sit
at the stadium right because there were
so many fights that broke out that they
didn't even want to have to bring
somebody up Uptown they were just they
brought the judge to the stadium they
called it Eagles court right and I've
seen and I see people I see three stops
but anyway but but to my point right
even in the city of Philadelphia
for that moment when you've got two
sides that want to go after each other
for that moment you put that crap aside
and you say what you know what we're all
Americans those two guys who would fight
at the at you know that game in
Philadelphia they beat each up later
they no no they'll fight each other but
if you went up and said something like
if you went to guy a and said do you
like America he'd back of course guy BG
like America of course we're fighting
over him spilling my beer right exactly
now you go into these you know well I
don't know how much the fans actually
care about this stuff but now you'll
actually have uh with the Olympics for
uh for instance in the soccer and the
kneeling and everything you'll have some
people being like America is evil and
racist the other person would be like I
like America they don't even I don't
think it was was it Daily Caller or
campus reform they went to Georgetown
and they were asking about this they're
asking about the Olympic team and they
and they went around interviewing
students like man on Street interviews
and they couldn't find now of course you
know there's editing and selection bias
Etc but they went through student after
student and they couldn't they every
single one was getting up there saying I
just don't know how I can root for this
team I can root for individual you know
I can root for Simone biles I can remove
it for you know various
um uh different athletes that are in
this but for the United States no I I
couldn't and if you notice that's how
they marketed the Olympic team this year
and what annoys me about that is that
then those athletes though Mega rupino
they flew over on American tax dollars
right like their team was funded by the
taxpayers so so they will take all of
the good that comes with it but then for
just that you don't have to say Megan
rapino you love America but for that one
moment as a courtesy to all of us who
pay our damn taxes and allow this to
happen for you shut your damn pie hole
and she couldn't do that because that
moment is not our moment it's still my
moment imagine when Megan rapino kicked
the goal all the fans were like you know
what you don't get to celebrate we're
going to do this and she'd be like wait
a second this is my moment right imagine
if you scored a touchdown and and the
fans were like you don't get to
celebrate that we all need to take a
knee and protest what's happening in
Bangladesh the wide receiver would be
like what the hell I just scored a
touchdown this is my moment no it's not
Megan rapino if you want to show your
proof your true protest moment every
time you scored a goal you should have
taken a knee right now but when she
scored
amazing who's that why has she been
disappeared from the entire narrative
the entire conversation right I say the
name of people like Tamara men's stock I
don't know who is that men's stock is
why isn't that name on everybody's right
front of Mind why isn't that friend of
mine The Narrative because she defied
The Narrative and it was some guy on
Twitter who went and found her speech
afterwards and she was the wrestler she
was the wrestler and she won the gold
and they went to her and she had the
show draped over her shoulders and when
they asked her they said how do you feel
about that that flag and she said I love
the United States of America I love
living there I love representing this
country it's the most happiest moment of
my entire life just to be here and you
could see the patriotism they wrote her
out of it was it she's was it Forest who
said that uh it might have been for us
maybe it was you that we're actually in
this country having a debate as to
whether this country should even exist
as far as yeah yeah yeah last week yeah
that's that's literally where we are
right now as a country right and so and
and just to like kind of
encapsulate all of this that we're
talking about from January 6 to uh the
decline of nationalism and patriotism
it's this is all for show by the way
right what's going on on an economic
level in this country is far beyond
anything that we've seen before the
Divergence of when you talk about class
when you talk about a new aristocracy
all of that's going on behind the scenes
and yet they throw all these things at
you in the foreground to make you forget
about it but when you go back and you
actually look at things that have
happened in just the past 10 years or
you know we're talking about the fall
you know the fall of Kabul the end of
Afghanistan right you know if you could
start with 911 and then just go through
everything that's happened in the past
20 years and then you know you combine
that with the rest of the 20th century
right and I know you guys were talking
about that last night that you really
realize there's been a whole lot that's
going on that actually matters that we
are being distracted about that we are
being told you know oh they want you
fighting you know amongst yourselves
over the different national anthems
because they know what they're doing
behind the scenes they're robbing you
blind they are putting you in a in
they're putting you into Perpetual
poverty they're putting you know they
want you to be Perpetual consumers and
surfs and everything else and that's why
the where it comes the abandoning
thousands of Americans in in Kabul is
unsurprising as tragic as it is it's
totally unsurprising because American
government has abandoned its people for
like you said 20 years they look at them
as deplorable we abandon people in
Toledo and we sent all their jobs to
China and Mexico we and we give them
fentanyl by the way we've abandoned
people in in Rural America we've a bit
the American government has Western
Maryland we talk about the divides of
the rich and the poor and the Haves and
the have-nots and who's making that
capitalism no it's government policy
right we've abandoned people to live in
the inner cities and look at what we've
done with them we've given them the
worst literally the worst education in
the developed world and um you want to
talk about maybe a rough or a corrupt
police force we've given them that we've
given them crime and we've given them no
education no opportunity to escape in
Rural America we've given them as lousy
schools with no jobs and no
opportunities and tons of fentanyl you
know if fentanyl across the border and
it was killing rich white liberal girls
in Manhattan it would have been stopped
like that but it's killing poor rednecks
and no one gives a damn not just
rednecks so where are you showed me in
Alaska so my point is we abandoned
people in Afghanistan American
government has abandoned the people for
for years now so let's talk about this
you got you guys went to Alaska I was
like an energy project right you know so
I sort of like let me let me like in
Alaska yeah I want to preface real quick
uh just to Prime this
we went from being energy independent to
dependent in the blink of an eye in the
blink of an eye and there's there's a
lot that contributes to it but then you
get you know Joe Biden's releasing the
sanctions on nordstream too you get uh
there's there's other pipelines they're
trying to do from Central Asia in the
Middle East up into into Europe they you
know the Biden Administration shuts down
Keystone they ban uh fracking on federal
lands then the Press has the gall to
come out and say Biden is not causing
high gas prices I just want to make sure
there's a few things that are clear
before we get into this when you shut
down the Keystone Pipeline and ban some
fracking speculators say wow Supply is
going to be strained it's a good time to
buy because in a few years it's gonna be
worth way more that instantly drives up
prices that hits you when you buy a
gallon of gas so uh so you weren't
necessarily doing an energy project or
or you know you were yeah I mean yes yes
and no it was that but also more than
just that and so when we look at these
discussions like Afghanistan the Middle
East Rare Earth minerals these elements
that China is gobbling up around the
world one belt one road uh the Petra
dollars so you know which obviously
Bitcoin is a huge hedge against right
all of these various discussions that go
on then we we never seem to turn around
and actually have the discussion of well
why does all of that stuff matter so
much why are we so beholden to all of
these various things is this really the
best way to run our country what if you
know and I I say this on Twitter and
I've been saying it more since I got
back from Alaska is what you know I
don't want to go straight full Fortress
America right you know I want to have
Commerce obviously I want to have trade
but at the same time is are we running
our country in a way that's most
beneficial for the American people who
live here now today and are we
developing our own resources for the
benefit of our people versus putting
ourselves at the mercy of these cartels
like OPEC which is a cartel literally
the actual Mexican cartels etc etc and
all of these other various things
because we've gotten ourselves head over
heels for these International agreements
rather than just looking internally
seeing what we have here and helping the
people of this country what if we spent
two trillion dollars and deployed our
military to Alaska to Nation build in
Alaska the resources the potential
energy I know what if we did that you
would have you would at least have a
tenfold return on your investment you
have a city yeah yeah you'd have a city
of Americans we've been mining copper as
a human race for about five thousand
years this was a great statistic that we
learned with this potential copper mine
we've been mining copper for about 5
right copper and lithium right the
amount of copper we have mined over the
past 5 000 years we will need twice that
if we are going to all Drive electric
vehicles by the year 2030. wow assuming
that we use copper wiring uh graphene
part of graphene
and if it works as a technology
fascinating but right now we use copper
yeah right so we we need copper your
your hybrid vehicle your your Prius and
it's going to come from somewhere has
about 80 pounds of copper and when now
we have a mandate and that's just the
Prius right the bigger ones and the
buses have up to 300 pounds of copper
that's where the electric motor that's
all that's all part of the battery
that's the battery yeah the coil the
coil yeah excuse me um
we all we're going to need a lot of
copper where are we going to get the
Copper from that's just a a legit
question right we're going to need an
awful lot of lithium we're going to need
Cobalt cadmium nickel gold graphite
China understands all of this by the way
very well one state that has all of
these things wow but it's our playground
and and rich white and I wouldn't say
liberals because it's a lot of
conservatives who look at Alaska as like
oh it's so pretty we shouldn't do
anything there and the reason why we
wanted to do this trip is because when
you meet alaskans who say I would really
like a job because there's nothing going
on here but if we open up this mine
I could maybe do something right and
we'll do the Mind responsibly because we
are so so wait let me tell a story about
how you actually get us to the mind
right this is this is like the you know
we wake up and we're in Anchorage and he
said Jack we're gonna go see the you
know and it's not a mine now it's it's
the deposit because not you know wow it
has been it's been tested but right now
there are no you know there's no holes
nothing being dug
isn't even a shovel in the ground there
right been waiting 17 years and so see
we're gonna check it out all right we're
gonna check it out sure whatever Daniel
whatever you want to do right it's like
I got my coffee and then we and then we
drive out to
uh there's so uh Alaska is Big right you
know and and that I don't mean there's
an understatement Alaska is massive the
size of Texas
I think it's I think it's more like
three and a half text size it's massive
Texas absolutely Max this is Texas Texas
anyone in the lower 38 who's never been
there cannot appreciate the scale of
Alaska we just have nothing else like it
on the map it gets squished right the
northern heaven let me let me I pulled
up an overlay image oh yeah and it
stretches from Central Michigan to
Central Minnesota the aleutians go if
you're in Alaska
uh in the easternmost point you are in
Florida and the westernmost Point you're
in Sacramento right whoa yes yeah
it stretches to be fair that's the
Aleutian Island if you include the
illusion so if we want to say just the
the the main land mass yeah I think it
would it would be fair to say Florida to
Nebraska yeah
wow so so we get in an airplane from
Anchorage we fly about about an hour
right and then we fly about an hour so
we're going across uh two bays to get to
this this tiny little remote middle of
nowhere village Village
that's just sitting there it's a native
Village and then and he says all right
we're gonna hang out here for a little
bit and then we're going to get a
helicopter I said what do you mean we're
not like we're not here already right
and we'll talk about the village in a
minute but he said no no we're gonna get
a helicopter something okay fine so we
get on the helicopter
and then the helicopter is what another
40 minutes or so so now you're in the
helicopter you're going 40 minutes and
you're just out and there's no roads
right so Aviation is actually huge in
Alaska because it's so big
um I think they have like one of the
highest per capita of private Aviation
and Pilots licenses and everything
because you have to you just if you want
to get from point A to point B the roads
are you know they're not great or
they're not they don't exist in many
cases and so you've got so we're in the
helicopter and a New Zealand pilot
actually kiwi and um told to look out
for Bears yeah total look out for bears
look out for Bears he says they attack
you know I was petrified
I've done this so many times I'm afraid
of bears no uh no we weren't armed um
but we did have helicopter though
um so we get all the way out there and
we're flying and it's and I'm look I'm
waiting for like these we you see all
those like those every it feels like
every other reality show is like set in
Alaska right so I'm looking for the
rivers and the streams and you flew over
some like at one point but then for most
of it it's just it's just Barren yep
it's just Baron desolate because it's
Tundra you know a lot of this is just
Tundra so it's it's frosted over rocks a
little bit of grass no trees
just yeah it literally you just sit no
trees whatsoever field a little tiny
bits and you think we could see bomb um
pine trees up there and so we get there
and we land and I'm like
and I'm like all right Daniel you made
me wake up at six in the morning to get
all the way out here and it's for this
one second I gotta see this it's the
same thing as what I was imagining
just nothing I mean literally just
nothing right and I'm like what is this
and Daniel looks at me and he says Jack
underneath your feet right now
is over a trillion dollars
in Copper
what and in six months that'll be 1.3
trillion yeah
exactly exactly and and I'm like and I'm
looking at him like
did we bring shovels
let's get the copper Daniel what are you
doing you know and and he's like we're
not allowed
like who says Washington
and then what kind of word and I'll let
you tell her but that's kind of where it
blows your mind that you're just out in
and by the way that's only one Valley
right you could go to the next about and
the next one over and there could be
that's all we know about right I I
understand uh you know environmentalism
for sure sure but we're not talking
about taking a a this is not a national
park of yeah fifth of Alaska and blowing
it up we're talking about probably what
is a square mile or or what it's even in
that is it even that oh it's yeah it's
probably probably square mile that's
probably enough square mile in Alaska
which is and could you I'm just I'm
sorry I would it was not it is not
literally it is not a postage stamp on a
football field what if we just took that
2 trillion over 20 years instead of
Afghanistan and said hey I got an idea
let's Nation build in our nation and uh
I mean not even Alaska we got Wyoming
and Montana how about that the reason
why we're doing it is not environmental
reasons that's the that's the facade is
environmental reasons environmental
concerns the reason why which is why I
started this organization and got into
the business because the people who own
copper rights in other countries fund
groups like the Sierra Club and the
national resources defense Council in an
Earth First and environmental defense
fund they fund these groups to say we
have to protect the Earth because they
own the mineral rights in Chile
Afghanistan the Taliban is going to now
sell them all to China right they own
this this is the biggest this is the big
thing with the Afghanistan that is in
China so China going in all those photos
you're seeing around of of China meeting
with the Taliban leaders right this is
all about the copper and the lithium
deposits in Afghanistan and I'm sorry
the 17 year old like kids like with the
tambourines and the hacky sack who is
saying we got to protect the Earth you
are a puppet so you've never been there
you are a puppet of a huge conglomerate
that does not want 1.3 trillion dollars
worth of copper on the market because it
will affect commodities prices and so
they want to keep it in places that have
no OSHA have no imagine a copper which
by the way this is
I would encourage you to look up copper
mine Chile waste copper Chile waste
giant strip mines massive pools of like
this colored liquid that's apparently
super toxic I mean you don't think
devastating and Chile is there making
sure that so you're saying there's no
like there's less
regulations that's the reason why we
like to mine in other countries because
you and you can use eight-year-old girls
right have have the and let's talk about
where that Cobalt is the Congo right the
largest Cobalt producer the mines are
owned by China but they're in the Congo
30 000 children slaves work there right
now I'm guilty I have cobalted my iPhone
as we talk oh so you admit it absolutely
it turned out you know but we just we
just pretend we it's not happening now
we could mine Cobalt in other countries
but it would be expensive so let's just
use the slave children in the Congo
because no one cares about the slave
children in the Congo so when we want to
open up a lithium Mine in Alaska or a
Cobalt mine or a gold mine or a copper
mine rather than hurt prices we hire a
bunch of hippie kids to say protect the
Earth and we start a group called moms
against asthma and we fund all of these
different people and they go and they
bang and they cry and they talk about
raping the Earth and it is all just one
but it is all there's another piece fly
there's another piece so it's after we
get back from there and I'm just and you
have that idea right and plus if you
actually look at the history of Alaska
so Alaska was a territory for a very
very long time since like post-civil
almost 100 years like post-civil war on
out and people didn't want to make it a
state originally because they were
concerned that it wouldn't be
self-sustaining because they they're
thinking hey this whole area is just a
wasteland why should we give them
statehood we're going to have to
completely carry them they're going to
pay their way on the way this is before
but then oil is discovered up there and
so in the 1950s it gets 59
um well they get the the statehood yep
so they get State and they say wait a
minute okay now you have the ability to
sustain yourselves there is a reason we
are going to give you statehood because
then that will give us access to the
resources down here that we need in the
lower 48. so the whole idea of Alaska
was that you will be given statehood and
that we will then be able to develop
these resources for the betterment of
the American people throughout the
country right these will be our Goods
these will be Amer we'll put actual
Americans to work we don't have to worry
about this all these trade issues and
you know the kids in the Congo Etc we
can do it all right here and we can set
it to our standards and do it just the
way we want then
so afterwards I'm sitting there thinking
and it's it's it is you kind of get that
like gold bug a little bit when you're
sitting there I still have it a little
bit where I'm like there's a trillion
like there's a trillion dollars in
Copper I just want to go can I just get
like a nugget like a little bit you know
you know my my wife she could use some
copper jewelry maybe right you know and
um she didn't come with us to the uh you
know the Wasteland and um but then he
took us to the village and I got to tell
you that of everything that we did and
we would also went up to Pluto we did
some of the touristy stuff while we were
up in Alaska but this this Village that
we went to the native Village
I I can't get some of the images out of
my head
and I can't get some of the stuff that
so we met with the leaders of the
village and I can't get some of the
stuff that they told me out of my head
the amount of poverty
that they live under 60 unemployment in
these towns right they and and the towns
are all and they're dying because there
there's no job it's so remote so people
understand it's so remote they have one
little building where they have that you
know that's the school they don't have
there's and you want to talk about
infrastructure right you know uh correct
me for one but there's no there wasn't
even a doctor there no like a doctor
like I'm not saying there wasn't a
doctor's office there wasn't even a
doctor a couple people had cell phones
but there's no internet yeah there was
like a physician's assistant I think was
the closest they came and then if you
wanted to see a doctor you'd better be
able to afford a plane ticket right
um there's no Bridge across the main
Lake that to get you anywhere yeah and
the flight to Anchorage was about 500 a
person so if you need to yeah go to get
your braces well you gotta on top of
that you need to pay the 500 flight to a
tank how long of a flight is it about an
hour and it reminded me of
um just some of the some places I've
seen in southeast like southeast Asia um
but this is America this is the United
States of America these are American
citizens the government is kind of like
oh I asked you this before the show you
guys that they forgive like they
basically are ignoring these people
because they're the descendants of
natives
I don't think that's why but that is
also what's that's also what's happening
because they'll now what's what's
different though is and Dan you know
this better than me the they don't have
the same type of I should I guess I
could say agreements that were made
between the US government and the
natives that you would see that you're
more that you're more used to seeing in
no no no not that natives are treated
well uh throughout you know U.S history
but I'm just saying that it's a
different situation that you would see
like reservations Etc throughout uh the
West in the U.S in the lower 48 the
contiguous U.S in Alaska they don't have
that this is because Alaska was formed
as a state after all these reservations
in the forms right so what's the
difference like how are they are they
abused in like some sort of specific way
I mean obviously it's economic it's all
economics and you know God help you if
you need police and if there's some
emergency that goes on there's no cops I
think if you are an Alaska native and
you are on your uh ancestral land and
no you there's not going to be Amazon
fulfillment center right no one's going
to move a factory there so what do you
do if you want to stay on your land what
what opportunities do you have well
natural resources seem to be the most
obvious but we've banned Timber right
the governor told us we had dinner with
the governor he said Rhode Island has a
bigger Timber industry than Alaska does
wow right because because why because
Alaska Alaska the largest state and the
smallest state Alaska that is because
temperature it's because it's it's our
little private park so here's past a lot
of rules here's a line here's a line
that somebody said and uh that we met up
there and they were like a lot of
there's a lot of transplants to Alaska
um you know from the little 40 people go
up there and I I can't wait to get back
honestly this I go to look I travel a
lot for um for my work I go to I've been
to I think 43 44 States plus Guam and uh
I loved Alaska I absolutely loved it I
can't wait to go back
um I get it I totally get it just you
know there for a week and I get it but
so we met somebody who had previously
been a DC staffer and one thing she was
saying was what a lot of people think of
Alaska is this is this giant beautiful
National Park
that I might like to visit someday and
so I'm going to oppose every single
effort to do anything that might disrupt
my potential dream of being there
someday because I have nothing no idea
what I'm talking about but every time
I've watched a you know a documentary or
a reality TV show they always show these
and there are some beautiful
Parts of Alaska that I do agree should
be preserved right and we're not talking
about those areas where we're not
talking about those national parks we're
talking about these wastelands deserts
and and essentially deserts right right
it's Tundras it's a type of desert
Arctic deserts that have resources that
are incredibly valuable to our people
number one to our development to our
progress and add additional benefit we
don't have to deal with China we don't
have to deal with the Taliban we don't
have to care about any of this stuff
anymore because it's right there and we
can do it with environmental stewardship
we can do it with respect for the Earth
and and Native communities and we get
the taxes and we get the jobs I mean the
fact that the president was on the one
hand closing down Anwar leases and then
saying we want OPEC to produce more oil
you say well wait a second why if you so
you're you're acknowledging that global
climate change is a myth because if if
OPEC is producing more oil then that's
global climate change so so right off
the bat your arguments about climate
change you've dismissed them by this
statement but if OPEC can produce the
oil why can't America produce the oil
why can't we get the jobs why can't we
get the tax revenue beyond that real
quick I mean there there are many we
have hyper centralized in many cities in
the United States why aren't we
investing in some of these dying towns
before you we get off or new places like
Alaska you've got to talk about the
General Store
oh and just the prices of you just just
tell the story just yeah I mean just uh
and we we go to this little store
um which is I'm gonna the store the
store that's the story
what time was this the little town is
called
Alaska ili
uh
and it's next two beautiful name isn't
it yeah yeah it's one of the largest
lakes in America actually is Lake
iliamna the lake that knows it's one of
the largest freshwater lakes
um in America I'm like where's where's
the Disney movie right where's where's
you know uh you know the kingdom of
treasures
that's the store is that the store that
was probably the name of the store yeah
so I did take some photos
in advance so I could show them to you
so this this um box you got like
everything there has to be brought in by
he has to show you the pictures because
he would not believe him this box of
Applejack boxes uh 10.50
family size Frosted Mini Wheats oh 10
bucks 22.50
half gallon of milk
16 bucks it's gonna be more 13.49 one of
the women talk about food shortages this
is where a woman says that's food
shortages soda is cheaper than milk and
she said and when you are seeing
American moms put Sprite in a baby's
bottle because they can't afford milk we
have a problem as a country and then but
we're saying but you can't open a pebble
mind because it's bad for the
environment but the local native women
who are literally putting Sprite in
their kids bottles because they can't
afford milk that's not my problem how
far is this mine what you call Pebble
mine Pebble mine how far is that from
the lake well that was the one we had to
take the the helicopter out it was like
40 miles or so like basically with the
pollution from the mine get into the
lake no and that's and that's what
they've looked in and that's the
argument that's the argument I got a
question is is there potential for
geothermal in Alaska
I can't answer I think there's a I think
there's potential for geothermal
everywhere quite frankly but I'm not
positive so Alaska's looked into it I
just looked up Iceland and they're 64
degrees north and Ileana is 60 degrees
north and so
I look at Iceland and you know having
been there and talked to a lot of the
locals they said that geothermal energy
really revolutionized and and pulled
people out of uh poverty and it used to
be a bunch of coal miners just very very
poor and then with geothermal now they
have greenhouses and they can produce
more of their own food in their own
country and now people live a lot better
I wonder if if the issue is just Alaska
is severely underdeveloped in not not
even in terms of a copper mine just in
terms of sustaining human life yeah
right and and that's what it sounds
awesome that's entirely the issue is
that is under development and it's it's
because of these and you talk to the
locals and even we met with local
politicians local leaders and they all
want this they're like you know we're
sitting with the local uh the town folk
and they were just like
do you think we want to live like this
and paying you know thirty dollars for a
gallon of milk yeah you know you think
we don't want a bridge you don't think
we don't want nice roads you know you
think we don't want a doctor and there's
a problem we're facing as a country and
I know I've talked about this before on
the podcast and it really is coming full
circle to a lot of what we've been
talking about tonight and you said get
out of cities early on all of our
policies are focused on living in big
cities you just said what about
revitalizing small town America right
there's a reason why Akron came about
and they're like well it makes more
sense to build brake pads in Mexico now
but for the people who are in Akron or
whatever the industry was that doesn't
solve their problem and what they're
left with is poverty and unemployment
and opioids right but they're all of our
policies are forcing people to America
we're forcing people to learn to code to
learn modern we don't want people to
live in Rural America and America Rural
America is dying as a consequence we met
the this this one small business owner
and not to get into all the details of
of that we met just a local guy who ran
a business out in one of the more rural
towns and he was told he said oh well if
you move to the city we'll give you tax
breaks we'll give you incentives we'll
build you a road we'll hook you up to
power it'll be great and he said no I
don't want to do that I I want to be
this is this is where I choose to run my
business I want to be here and they say
okay then you'll have to pay us
to get your road to get your waste to
get your electricity hooked up you'll
have to pay us to build all that
infrastructure and put it out there but
it will give you all the incentives if
you come and move into this look at the
way we've bend over backwards when we
want to build a baseball stadium or a
football stadium look at the incentives
that Cuomo and de Blasio gave Amazon to
move into Queens
imagine if they had made that for
Buffalo or Utica or one of those Upstate
New York cities that is dying no one
cares about those cities because what do
they want you to do they want you to go
to Queens this is what I want you to
come to DC
they want you to go to Urban America
because that's where the power is that's
what the green New Deal is structured
for combustion engine who reads the
combustion engine alaskans do if you
want to get around when is it what what
is an electric car going to do in Alaska
Because by the way in case people forgot
the electric car does not work at below
freezing temperatures so Alaska can't
use electric cars or electric planes
right so we're we're having all of these
policies in this Electric Car Works
below freezing but
nothing not below 20 degrees it will not
charge it won't charge you will not get
a charge
there were tons of stories during the
Chicago polar vortex of people with
Teslas saying WTF I got my 140 000 Tesla
plugged in and but at negative no it's
it's negative temperatures but it does
not even catch a charge but you can you
can like heat the garage that it's in
and it'll work maybe you could do that
I'm not sure wind turbines at the same
temperature don't don't get a charge
either now they're spinning
up a storm but at negative temperatures
they cannot get like the generated
electricity is that a it's a huge
efficiency but that's just technology
that's that was a part of the Texas
issue that's just the technology why
can't we talk about it so you're saying
that's another I shouldn't drive my
Tesla in the winter I'm saying at below
freezing temperatures your Tesla is
useless now I'm sure they will improve
the technology eventually that heater in
it but but that is that is a real
problem right now really just like in
Cloudy weather your solar panels don't
do very well and I know this because I
have some solar Gates on my farm and
when the snow caps cover when we get
good snowstorms and it snows on the
panels if you don't go out and clear it
off and you let a whole day go by and
then you try to open the gate Gate's not
opening because I can't remember charge
I can't remember when I got my Tesla but
maybe it was before winter this will be
fun we'll see what happens again
negative temperatures I'm not talking
about you know 30 degrees but it's our
apartment doesn't get that cold here our
garage is is uh um peripherally heated
we don't have a heater in the garage but
it's connected to the house so it's
still gets heat so it'll probably be
like 40 or 50 in the garage but you're
probably okay it'll charge and it'll
drive that's all that really matters
right yeah but I you know I worked for
when I worked for uh at O'Hare Airport
O'Hare Airport for American Eagle
Airlines they had you know you know the
tugs that they used to card around bags
they had electric ones yeah and they had
gas ones the electric ones barely worked
in winter
interesting no joke yeah so you'd have
to charge them up and you'd be driving
you got this really crappy LED that says
like you know 70 left and you're
worrying you're driving it and in the
winter it would just go it was like on a
golf course if you can get the electric
golf cart or the gas one everyone tries
to get the gas one yep
um but again these are just the policies
that our government is forcing on us
that when you question them kind of like
when you questioned kovid you're you're
ostracized and you're told to shut your
damn mouth right we have policies that
are saying we're all going to be driving
electric vehicles but our strategic
brownouts and blackouts because of
electric shortages they don't care about
that what happens in California when
whole neighborhoods or without their
consent
they are they are shut off from the grid
to protect the Integrity of the grid and
you're plugging in your car and you wake
up and now your car doesn't work and you
say well you're the one who forced me to
get the damn electric car and at the
same time you're turning off my power
but the future they want is where no one
owns a car
which makes sense in urban America right
and I didn't have a car growing up as a
kid I have my parents car thanks man
pull up an app and you'll type in your
address and a self-driving car will pull
up and you'll get in and it'll take you
where you want to go and you'll get out
I'm never getting into something on your
list of approved uh common approved
locations approved destinations right
that's right you know and so and then we
track where you've gone and by the way
where has Jack passovic gone in his soul
right and then when and then when Nancy
Pelosi wants to find out all my
movements from April 2020 to January
2021. you should have been giving them
ideas but why can't this goes over to
all of your Uber why is it you know what
if Uber is a good citizen they would
voluntarily turn over those records they
would also have barcodes on the on the
passenger door so you got to scan before
you get in the card of course yeah to
make sure you have your vaccine exactly
I once had somebody get in my car so I
was like I was I was pulled over near uh
you know building in Chicago and then I
was sitting in my car like typing in my
GPS my doors were unlocked because I
just got in and then someone walks up
opens the door and sits down in the back
and I was like yo what and he's like hey
and then I was like dude get out of my
car and he was like is this Uber and I
was like No And he was like oh oh man
and he got up and left and I'm like I
think that's actually a Family Guy
episode
that's that's scary I know I'll unlock
my door like wow scary that someone
could be that stupid also that you're
like don't look at the license plate and
I know I always check the license plate
say their name when you get in the car
yeah yeah the driver's name they say
your name Uber for Ian well I say I say
Daniel actually but yeah
yeah but this is the future you'll own
nothing and you'll be happy yeah you
won't own your house you'll rent it you
won't own the car you'll like Rockwell
own all the houses that's right and they
want and by the way I don't know if you
even heard all this but uh
uh because I was on a I was on a text
thread but I don't know if you were on
it that that area that we're talking
about right now and Pebble and Ileana
BlackRock is all over it oh yeah they
have been because they were telling us
they said they had a private plane that
flew it was like a week before we were
there and they had this private jet that
came in and then there was another one
that came a week just just a week ago
like just last week and then I was
getting Tech because I'm in
communication with some of the people we
you know share contact info and and they
said BlackRock just came back again and
probably to make sure it never opened
they said they probably own Mining
rights
they think they were at the lodge and
you know they have their beautiful
palatial you know fishing lodge and
their hunting lodge for the one percent
that's up there and and they said well
who is this and they said well because
it's it's so small you gotta understand
that like when somebody big like that
comes to town you you know everybody
knows but they checked the plane out and
it was like you know double trusted so
you couldn't really tell but everybody
knew hey this is a black rock and a
couple of billionaire owners who give
hugely to these green groups to stop
them from to stop production stuff
Michael Bloomberg
Bill Gates
uh um oh there's the Jeff Bezos those
three in particular give Michael
Bloomers give over billions of dollars
to these green groups you want to tell
this story those three names the day
after the day after that happened
Bloomberg and we we were going to go on
our way up to Pluto and that's all so
that's all the way up the north North
Slope of Alaska and the you know I wake
up I do my morning I'm sure you do the
same thing you wake up you do your
morning news scan right you know it's
what's hitting what's popping what's out
there what I want to talk about you know
for the timeline and I see this one that
hits and it's like is this a simulation
Bezos Bloomberg and Gates have all gone
in and invested in an energy and mineral
exploration firm lithium and Cobalt
lithium and Cobalt in Greenland
it was one of the best ideas that came
out of the Trump Administration was
buying Greenland it would be like in
Alaska too right you know same idea it
would grant us so much access to another
set of minerals and who's going to go in
there now it's the billionaires it's
China is getting all over there you guys
real quick do you guys uh know under
what jurisdiction Greenland is
Denmark's microscopic and they got this
massive look at this massive piece we
need to liberate the people of Greenland
from the oppressive colonization of the
Kingdom of Denmark this
those same billionaires will spend a
freaking Fortune to stop mining in
America but they will open a mine in
another country
did he set this up somehow for like to
have this kind of timing was the regime
of Alaska must be toppled yeah we've
discovered oil it's time to send in the
troops yes exactly exactly freedom
freedom let's invade the let's you know
let's get the neocons on board we're
going to invade the United States
here yeah one of my most despised
political figures who ran for president
last time was as uh Tom steyer and he
ran
I disliked I'm sorry you I'm like real
loathing for him because he pushes the
green envelope very very hard he's all
about the green issue but he is the lar
one of the largest investors his hedge
fund in uh Indonesian Chinese Malaysian
uh coal and mineral rights companies and
it's like you have no problem of an
eight-year-old girl in China what do you
think blackrock's investing in tripling
their investments in China you will be
damned if a guy in West Virginia will
work on a coal mine but like a
nine-year-old girl in Malaysia totally
cool for it man all for it and and they
all just applaud him and say he just
loves the Earth so much that is why I
started this organization because it is
such a uh I I want to use a vulgar
phrase and I can't say it it is such a
lie the whole the whole green movement
is one big scam and I'm an
environmentalist and I pride myself we
were talking earlier about my chickens
and my sheep and my turkeys and I love
the Earth I'm an environmentalist I love
nature I live off the grid I have a well
I
he get out of cities but we need to
acknowledge that this is one huge lie
it's one huge grift and grift
Griff just makes me so angry we
should go to super chats yeah if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel and go to
timcast can I become a member so that
you can get access to the exclusive
member segment coming up around 11 or so
p.m before we throw that out could I
tell one quick other story just from
Alaska because you have to it's right so
we talk about the animals and
environments so we go up to prudo Bay
and this is where the actual oil
operation the the major majority ones
were found these are more than Texas you
know it's the Saudi Arabia of oil in our
own borders right it's way up there
Arctic Circle we're on the Arctic Ocean
I was gonna jump in he stopped me
um I was totally gonna jump in by the
way in the water there are polar bears
and I was like you know what I will
fight
Jack I will take out those pullers yes
but anyway anyway so we're driving
around up there and we go through we go
past the pipeline and of course remember
this is the most this hugely
controversial transalaska pipeline they
say we're going to put the pipeline in
right and it's gonna and then what did
they say it's gonna oh it's gonna hurt
the Caribou It's Gonna Hurt the reindeer
it's gonna hurt them as we're driving by
I'm sitting there I'm like set this up
we see a herd of caribou like frolicking
in the meadow
right in front of the pipeline and I'm
like if you have a guy with like a
walkie-talkie with the trailer that's
like sitting back there all right all
right we're driving by with it's like
you know Jurassic Park when they drive
by but they couldn't see anything at
first you know and then and then we go
for another you know like another five
minutes and we see muskox and we see
this whole family of muskox out there
grazing and enjoying the land and I'm
and like literally on the area that's
right next to the oil rigs right and I'm
saying and not even like out in the you
know you know out in the more the more
Wilderness part and I was sitting there
like he he must have said this is like
when Chairman Mao would go in you know
on the train to inspect the crop you
know and they say oh everything's great
chairman look how wonderful your
policies have been right and then they
like you know set everything up one spot
for him yeah right and it was no we saw
it
would you go would you take us would you
go up with us you know if uh come on
Lydia well I'll do my trip up there when
starlink is available we can take the
show on the road
you got to do do a week you do a week
and you do one one night in each
different space we have a drive there it
would take us like a month to get there
oh we'll play it we can ship the car I
promise we can't you know we we do more
than just the show here we got a bunch
of shows so it's really difficult for me
to travel we could ship the car and then
fly up when it's there exactly ship the
trailer
we'll build the Alaska Studio yeah so
that we can fly there on the weekend
we'll get you a studio we'll get you a
studio cast Castle North and then our
our guests you know when we have people
uh who come on the show they'll fly from
DC instead of just driving and they'll
fly to Alaska and fly to Alaska right
yeah you know I uh uh I mean Tim you're
coming I I don't think the answer is 100
100 no I think it's entirely possible
that we could do a small remote Studio
it's not particularly expensive to get a
base level set up for a podcast and so
considering I suppose the the pulling
the resources in is the hard part but
getting the space
getting the internet's the hard part so
we need startling I already paid my
deposit on starlink I hope it's soon me
too they said it's supposed to be this
year or not well it's already it's
already up it's uh in in New York it's
up oh so if you're a New York resident
you probably already got your starlink
I'm not we're lower on the East Coast so
they're saying late this year so we're
we're a month to away to getting
starlink and 100 megabits up and down
you can put it you're not supposed to do
this but apparently you can put it on a
car and so long as you're within the
satellite range because you'd have to be
under the yeah that is awful so once it
goes Nationwide we'll be able to drive
around the entire country and always
have high-speed internet even right so
you know the difference the difference
is that you would be instead of so when
you're when you're traveling now you're
switching between towers as you're
constantly going it's not possible what
this would do is you would be you would
be switching between satellites as they
go over we could theoretically do a show
in so you'd be happy like a tour bus and
be handoffs yeah but with the satellite
there's nothing is not you have 500
miles before you get to 100 that's the
that's the range well obviously yes the
range is obviously different yeah yeah
so once once we get once uh uh EarthLink
is is Nationwide even up into Alaska we
can drive anywhere
yeah so they have EarthLink and starlink
once you said when EarthLink is oh yeah
no I think EarthLink is a different
satellite company let's go to super
chats yeah
Jurassic Josh says when saki said that
no Americans are stranded in Kabul does
that mean she's lying or did she mean
that 15K Americans are just dead already
uh so what so it is a lie and it's it's
a a lie because she's using weasel words
right when she says they're not stranded
that she's you know then trying to say
like well because we're there to help
them
get them out right yeah so she's playing
a semantic game here's the way I explain
it which is a lot when uh Ian you know
he goes to the mall and his car breaks
down he calls me and says yo my car
broke down I'm stranded at the mall I
say hey I'll come and pick you up but
there's a there's a bunch of traffic so
I'll try and get there all right then as
I'm leaving I'm gonna getting in my car
and uh you know someone asks me like oh
hey where you going Ian is stranded at
the mall so I'm gonna go try and pick
him up
now could now compare that to what's
happening in Afghanistan a bunch of
Americans have no way out because the
airport's locked down and jenseki says
we're going to go and try and pick them
up therefore they're not stranded
because we're on our way oh they're
literally straight on the way that's why
you are going just just to throw this
out there um I've actually been told
that it's uh you're you're hearing a lot
about these like private groups that are
trying to go over and get people out
um it's the state department they're
shutting down a lot of this stuff it's
not even the military it's they're
getting in I've spoken to members of
Congress about this I've spoken to
active duty people about this it's State
Department that's coming up towards
because they want everything to be
centralized they want everyone to be
accounted for when and we all and and in
in a regular situation sure that would
be fine
but they're K they're sticking with the
deadline and come
August 31st we are going to see
stampedes we're going to see uh bloody
altercations we're going to see
shootouts you're gonna you're it is
going to be a a human waste and there
are still several thousand people who
are in the rooms that hadn't even gotten
to Kabul right people are fleeing to
Cobble rich and Bagram Air Force Base is
45 miles right middle of nowhere they
abandoned in the middle middle of
nowhere where there were people who were
telling uh Millie and all and from what
I heard that Austin wanted to do this is
send in the Rangers and take it back
jump in take it back what the television
doesn't have like battalions you know
that are like marching around right you
go in there and you do Ranger stuff and
you take care of it right let's uh they
said no they didn't want to Blackhawk
Down we got yeah I heard that yeah
deliopolis says what do you believe
would happen to wokeness if the U.S
government collapsed tomorrow how would
this affect the broader Western world
I don't know if woke is is an
intrinsically American thing I mean I
think I think America is pushing it a
lot more than other countries but
um I think it's a collapse of Western
value thing so maybe it's it's it's
ringleader would uh
it you know would slow it down if
America was gone but but it it's just
it's another manifestation of of well
when you saying government I kind of get
the sense though that he he means more
of like the American system I think
women's would evaporate I think it would
be difficult I mean think of any think
of any post-apocalyptic
movie or series you've ever seen does
anybody drive up to the Outpost and say
you know hey let me in you know the you
know the the cannibals are after me and
they say what are your pronouns you know
yeahness only exists within the secure
bubble of the US you know imperialism I
feel like there would be armed militia
roving smoke militias yeah that are like
submit or they're just Massacre people
if there's no rule of laws I I don't
think you're wrong about that I think to
the extent of that you're not wrong but
that would be like the first week and
then all of the the the the Commando
ex-military veterans who are anti-woke
would laugh at their failed tactics and
their inexperience and they get swept
out but we're saying just America's gone
Canada's fine England's fine Australia I
I think it lit I mean I think America is
slow to the world well in America it
would oh in America oh I think I'm
worldwide oh and America could be gone
yeah I'm talking like a full-on collapse
forces
um he was in the the Rangers obviously
and he says whenever I bring up violence
and you have woke refugees A Way Forward
he keeps reminding me that
when it comes to violence one percent of
the people are extremely good at it and
that is who's going to take control if
there's ever a vacuum look I always say
this and I'll say it again you know
people want to get into that
conversation about oh you know country
versus cities what would happen it's
it's and and yeah I there obviously are
a lot of guns in uh in the country and
rural areas there's a lot of guns in
cities too yeah right and there's groups
called gangs and you can't Overlook that
all right T says if you read this I'll
subscribe to the website I got you there
you go there you go that's it you're
done you're done now you're done Joshua
Joshua Ryman says Ryman says
terrifyingly started uh starting to
remind me of Saddam in the bath party
Purge of Iraq wake up America we are all
next yeah so do you guys know that what
was that all like the history of that
that was like uh when we went into Iraq
that was the U.S yeah the U.S Purgatory
party his uh saddam's cabinet basically
and then they all became unemployed they
created even more unemployment then they
became the Taliban but if you're as well
well I uh eventually you know uh Isis
well so there was no well first it was
al-Qaeda in Iraq so there was no Al
Qaeda in Iraq prior to the invasion in
the toppling of saddam's regime saddam's
regime had been against them uh you know
sort of like this these uh radical Islam
islamists and then when you forced the
bath party and keep in mind if you were
a party member you were out right you're
out of government you're out of the
military right so you've got all these
people now who are trying to figure out
something to do and they see the the
oppressors they see the occupiers they
view the us as this occupying force and
this gets into the failures of coin this
gets into fourth generation Warfare that
you know if you look like the occupier
and this is by the way the same for the
Taliban right you know in a sense and
I'm just talking about the
uh the 4gw aspect of it that if you are
an 18 year old right an Afghan boy and
you you are 18 today you have no idea
what 9 11 was you just know that there's
been some country that's occupying your
land that doesn't speak your language
that doesn't believe uh in your religion
that uh has all all sorts of values and
demands that they're making of you that
have no connection whatsoever to your
cultural experience the thing or the way
that your people live and they are they
are walking around marching around with
their guns telling you how to live right
that's that's your view all right djm
says keep it the good work Tim regarding
covet and vaccine mandates what worries
me is if vaccines and boosters are
mandatory a tarantical government can
put undesirables on no vax lists Watch
Gattaca just watch is that what they do
that's correct well it's not about it's
it's not about vaccines but what it is
about is um they call you valid valids
and invalids so so if you are a valid
that means it's about Eugenics right so
it's you have good genes you are a
designer baby uh your your parents set
you up for Success versus if you are a a
natural birth or what they call a faith
child or a love child right yeah yeah um
then you're considered an invalid and
you are sent to you you're a
second-class citizen because well I mean
you didn't even have your booster isn't
there like a pilot who's lying or
something well so yeah the whole Crux
historian is Ethan Hawke and he is so he
was a natural birth but his brother was
a designer baby
and then he what he does is he becomes a
I think they call it a a borrowed ladder
is the phrase they use and where he
actually steals the identity not steals
but it's he uh takes the identity of
someone else so that he's able to get
into this it's sort of like the space
program and then he has to compete and
physically and mentally and do
everything at the level of one of the
valids all while protecting his own
genetic material because if anyone finds
any DNA Etc orbitals in it by the way
it's like what they're doing now and you
try to steal someone's covert passport
to get into a bar in Manhattan exactly
because what happens is that somebody uh
somebody who was an athlete in his Jude
Law's character gets into a car accident
well don't give away the whole story
so he so he gets into an accident he's
not using his identity anymore so he
says well I'll I'll pay to you know let
somebody use my identity all right Ethan
Ethan Kraus says amazing film uh Ethan
says Tim I doubt you're aware of this
but the governor of Guam is trying to
mandate vaccines for everyone 12 and
older similar to those in New York and
L.A people people here are speaking up
and taking a stand against lockdown good
against lockdown Lou a lot of good
memories in Guam spent uh I was there
twice or you know stationed there and
then deployed out to various points of
East Asia
um you know agonya agat
um Santa Rosita all the different or
Santa read excuse me Santa Rita all the
nice little towns and areas beautiful
beautiful island and you know it is not
cheap to get there but if anyone has the
opportunity I highly highly recommend
visiting Guam
all right let's see by the way a lot of
World War II history there as well a lot
of World War II history Never Summer
says Jack you should you should set up a
dead man switch with all the dirt you
have if you don't have one
like like something happens to me
I can't even begin to describe the
things that my network of people that
are currently in the White House and the
government would do should something
happen to me just I'm just gonna leave
it at that good
all right Jordan Chapman says been
listening since 2015. Tim in regards to
anime quick question subbed or dubbed
I'm a subbed guy myself I wanted to ask
a long time ago but I'm a third shift
guy and I'm not normally awake for the
live shimcast uh subbed definitely
subbed I like dubs I like the voice
actors but subbed is you know the way to
go listening since 15 that's awesome oh
yeah that's fantastic dubs has gotten
better the dubs have gotten better the
doves have gotten they're not like they
used to be but you know what like I'm
not a huge anime guy but I will just say
in general dubs have gotten better I
like subs for everything because I like
actually hearing other languages yeah
yeah and also you know if you're
learning the language too it's actually
a great like when I was learning Chinese
that's one thing I did a lot absolutely
I I uh one of the guys that I worked
with in Turkey learned English and asked
him how he says watch Family Guy yeah
but you know what I love you know I used
to watch I just when I I used to watch
anime a lot more all subbed I actually
started learning Japanese I've lost a
lot of it but then it's really
interesting when you watch it when you
watch the subs you see the translations
and you're like hey that's not what it
said like they missed Nuance or context
or often what they do is they'll they'll
change the translation a little bit
because they think it contextually see
this is this is you know we've got my
wife the linguist who's sitting over
here she's like speaks eight languages
you know so like that's really the one
you ask that question watching uh and
Jesus said that yeah like a lot because
she watches a lot of things that where
she speaks she knows both languages and
she just says like no that like do you
speak French
so I was watching Amelie yeah you guys
have seen Amelie right right I have not
and I watched it with a french guy and
he kept pointing out where they
oversimplified the sub right exactly
yeah you know so it was really really
interesting when there's like there was
one specific part and he was like oh wow
they cut out like a whole sentence and I
was like really like I don't even know I
don't speak French I have no idea yeah
it's amazing
all right let's see let's see where we
are
camel of the Mojave says don't
understand we have to kill puppies or
people might try to go outside and adopt
them now you guys heard about what
happened in Australia that's
unbelievable is it because they think
kovid's in the dogs was it was it really
was it really puppies it was I don't
know if it was a rescue dogs but they
were worried about people they were
young their house and go to the shelter
they were like we're not supposed to
leave your house so let's just kill all
the dogs and that way no one will leave
their house oh my God and they killed
they put down several cut off people's
legs so they can't walk exactly outside
what the heck Simon Ecker says I'm in
New Zealand and we're basically
Australia light at the moment our prime
minister is using lines like be kind and
team of five million to force people to
do their bidding authoritarianism is
running Rife and it's awful well uh I
think the sad reality for you is that
everybody knows New Zealand is
Australia's Canada so I'm sorry
Australia is going to do something you
know New Zealand no the reality is that
New Zealand's actually thousands of
miles away from Australia and people
don't know that when you fly between
them you're like oh wait a minute yeah
the Pacific is Big
um I'm I'm married to an Australian and
I always joke like do you take the
bridge when you go to New Zealand it
doesn't it doesn't get any laughs but I
think it's funny
General biochemistry with some criticism
so cops are supposed to lose their jobs
to stand up but you won't say certain
words on YouTube so you don't lose your
channel lead the charge well the officer
is a big difference between saying
there's a 50 year old woman with a
firearm who accidentally crossed one of
the borders let's put her in prison and
someone being like hey they're censoring
us so I set up a website where we can
speak uncensored I want to keep this
channel running so we can keep reminding
people that these conversations will
continue to happen in a place where
we're safe and protected so big
difference between resist and well I'm
gonna blindly enforce violations of the
Constitution but uh you know look am I
happy with YouTube censoring everybody
no and that's why we decided to create a
website where this wouldn't happen so
these cops can simply say I will will
not violate the constitution and I will
tell you this the the big challenge with
censorship is do we sacrifice the 99
things we need to say for the one thing
that we need to say and and it really
isn't easy just say yes or no if the
solution right now is we can create a
website use YouTube as a main platform
to show people that we're here and we're
talking and then let them know the
website exists where we can do
independent journalism it works but I
will tell you this if it ever comes to a
point where we have hard and direct
proof of something specific and it means
that we're going to get banned I'm we're
going to say it I made videos about that
CIA guy whose name we can't say I won't
say it now because at this point I think
it's years later and it's pointless and
I got into a fight with people at
YouTube when they deleted my videos
simply for talking about a news story I
actually threatened to republish the
video on every channel at every hour I
normally would so I'd have like six
uploads in one day well Charming well do
I sacrifice everything you know to your
point as well that you know there are
other localities that are actively
trying to recruit police officers that
number one aren't enforcing stuff like
this and number two aren't going to
persecute you the way they persecute
like a Derek Chauvin for do doing your
job and following the guidelines that
are set up before you and you could then
have the option of going to one of those
where a you're going to be treated
better and B you're probably not going
to be asked to enforce these kinds of
things well we got a super chat from
Adam Wayne so I'm not saying by the way
you know for all the cops that you know
follow me I get it I feel you but when I
say get out of cities
I applies to you too Adam Wayne says Tim
is right I quit law enforcement after a
successful career when Virginia enacted
red flag laws wow my reputation was
destroyed but I'm proud you must stand
for something you or you will fall for
anything wow there is the challenge
though in that you know if you have no
choice you quit but then what's left
they rehire someone who's willing to do
those awful things yeah so it's not it's
not easy right in this instance
maybe maybe to the cops out there and a
lot of them have already done this so
I'm not trying I'm not trying to
disrespect literally every person who's
a cop I'm saying that there are cops who
do these things if you're a cop and they
say hey violent the Constitution just go
I'm not gonna do it and then be like
well then you know uh fire me or you
know go to your union or resist uh and
then if they boot you they boot you so
I'll put it this way perhaps the cops
shouldn't quit perhaps they should just
refuse unlawful or unconstitutional
orders as much as I won't quit YouTube
but I'll create a a place where we can
continue to do the right thing if
YouTube bans me we've got an alternative
and we'll accept that and if you get
fired because you refuse to violate the
law of the Constitution you know well
then you stood up for what you believed
in I've had uh I've had people that um
that I used to serve with in the Intel
community that uh that have come up to
me since I left and they've said Jack
you know
what you do now is what you were meant
to do and we we love every minute of
serving with you but what you're doing
now is you know everybody thought I was
crazy like you should have seen the
looks I got when I was like I'm putting
papers they're like I had a government
job like you know what are you gonna do
to me right I couldn't see the rest of
my life
and uh you know and they're like you
wanted to go do what you know exactly
when I started getting you know offers
and kind of had this this other path
open up but now I've actually had people
come back to me and say you know what
you made the right choice
especially with what's going on the IC
now Justice die says hey Tim you should
have G Edward Griffin on with Michael
malice and Alex Jones
yes yes we should it's a good show that
would be a fantastic show the new studio
that we're building we have a much
bigger table we can accommodate up to
eight different people wow I don't I
don't I don't plan on having eight
people it's a lot of voices right it'd
be way too much but um you know we have
five right now and sometimes you know
you know we got to uh you know Tanya's
over here she could get a microphone
we could always just uh so what we're
actually planning on doing is just that
we're gonna have a couch in the back
where you see that actually is a good
option then you could kind of you know
there would be a microphone for you you
know so when guests are here and they're
you know chiming in periodically they'd
be a part of the conversation I like
them we're almost
at the yeah
come on say hi
here she is folks hello everybody
so what do you what do you like better
subbed or dubbed subbed subbed always
yes watch all the movies I love how we
watched all the um serious Japanese
remember that that's right but there's
this uh Japanese uh detective series you
watch I mean it's all subbed like the
whole all the way through cool
um question though what of all the
languages you know what's your favorite
do you have a favorite language
I'm a linguist
it's Italian
she loves speaking Italian we're in
Italy you were like you're doing the
fingers
do you dream in lots of different
languages
actually
um two languages uh German Russian
English just two oh like a German
Russian hybrid
what languages do you speak
um
all right all right enough showing off
we get it we get it
all right let's see let's read we got
the ocean rescue says Tim I'm a rescue
swimmer in the Coast Guard it's
difficult for us to acquire new aircraft
as we rely heavily on Navy hand-me-down
uh hilo's wow yeah the Blackhawks and
Taliban control are badly needed here
for our own aging Fleet to save American
lives at home hey nation building in
Alaska I saw I saw one they had like a
it was like a meme but it was like a um
you know those Facebook marketplaces and
they're like 80 million dollars one used
helicopter
could you imagine it's like we've had to
abandon our Air Force Base because
American citizens have overrun it I
guess we're going to ask them nicely to
not yeah and the state department
earlier is they've they made some
comment like well they do have a lot of
that equipment but you know they'll have
a hard time getting parts they'll have a
hard time keeping it up and someone was
like Iran still uses the equipment they
stole from 1979 yeah and still uses the
effort literally they find parts some of
those were built in the 50s by the way
yeah the the platforms were built in the
50s Iran got them in 79 during the
Revelation they're still up and running
and they're still up and running that's
made better than Ryan Knoll says I
understand your argument Tim but these
restaurants and Mom and Pop shops in New
York have been crippled for over a year
their businesses are hanging on by a
thread and probably near bankruptcy and
you know what that wouldn't have been
the case if they all collectively said
no yeah it's because they complied with
unlawful and unconstitutional government
edicts so again what you're saying too
will they will reap the benefits of
their own actions it's it's all what
you're also saying
you know not just leave the cities but
like stand together and fight back
right do if you do that non-violent
Civil Disobedience yeah is like an
American Pastime yeah and I'm I I and
I'm saying this lightly I realize I'm
not a restaurant owner but I mean how
many bars did I go into starting at 15
that they never carted me once you know
now all of a sudden it's like whoa whoa
whoa we need to see your ID yeah it's
like you know like there are a lot of
laws that you kind of turn a blind eye
to in that industry so no I'm not going
to stop people at the door and say I'm
sorry I need to get your everyone here
vaccinated yeah okay everyone come on
inside just like when they ask you are
you over 21 uh yes yes I am sir okay
good you know I'm sorry well and
actually what you just said that that
non-violent Civil Disobedience right
this is you know I say this as a
Catholic and a lot of people get this
part of the Bible wrong when someone
slaps you turn the other cheek right uh
Jesus isn't saying that oh you should
just submit and be tolerant and let
people do whatever they want it's no
he's talking about Defiance right it's
that it's that Defiance of okay you've
slapped me I'm not going to submit slap
me again right I've heard tibets keep
doing it that's because the Romans would
use one hand to wipe their butt and so
they didn't touch people with that uh
not the Romans but the people that
interview the region so if you hit him
with one hand it was natural to strike
someone with one hand you'd turn the
other cheek so that they had to touch
you with the other hand that's correct
yeah was it the filthy hand and so it
was kind of like an insult to the person
like you right so it's in your field
right so you're actually putting this
this is it's more contextual right but
the the idea being that
um then they would have to strike you
with the other hand so that's an insult
to them because you would have had to
lower because if you were not someone of
the same social status then I wouldn't
be able to treat you as some of the same
social status because you're just
someone I can slap around
all right Stephen shulk says Tim
geothermal works great in Iceland
because it's a volcanic island and is a
dividing point for tectonic plights so
the crust is thinner there it also
smells like farts yeah oh really yeah
have you been there I've not but there's
also Alaska also has huge electronic
activities
I mean we passed three active volcanoes
on the flight to Ileana so three at once
this is this is uh what do they call it
this is not normal this is very very
weird to have three active volcanoes in
a chain I'll go up at once according to
this articles and that's why they also
have copper because copper is only found
in seismics
right that's why Chile has copper so
they're like why don't we just dig for
copper somewhere else that's not how I
hear Australia is like the number one
copying minoring country than Chile is
number two is that I know I know
Australia has a ton of of coal it's the
world's largest cold producer I I
wouldn't be surprised if they have
copper I mean Australia has everything
and snakes definitely all right we'll do
a couple more here
we got Tina Collette saying Jack I live
in Wyoming I see deer and antelopes
scratching themselves on gas Wells we
have uranium and rare Earth mineral but
they are literally on sacred ground
Google Bear Lodge Devil's Tower wow
interesting all right we'll do this one
more we got Eric a he says Ian I
appreciate your high ideals but we're
coming to the Hard Men history you need
to harden up we've been comfy far too
long at ease at having someone else
fight for them high ideals are a luxury
of a comfortable
Society I mentioned but yeah absolutely
I agree I think of the founding fathers
a lot like Ben Franklin didn't fight I
don't know if he ever picked up a rifle
and killed anyone but he stayed positive
and wrote documents that would allow us
like we're working on the fediverse and
I know that we're getting closer to
completion this can like you know
liberate people's social media if you
can subscribe to people with crypto
remember Franklin was a lot older yeah
30 years older than Jefferson he's
considerably older like 71. so he was he
was kind of like the old you know the
Wise Old Man of the group at the time
um but you know of course Washington
fought but uh you know Jefferson you
know didn't fight himself
um but but right so Franklin was sort of
that you know that older wiser I'm gonna
try to you know make sure that I can
keep the North and South together you
know work over the Declaration kind of
build a system this all makes sense
assuming that we've six that we won
built a system that will sustain that
new thing that we won then it will be
easier to win because the system will
already be there ready for us to support
it
that's my mentality my friends thank you
all so much it's been a blast hanging
out with everybody and for everybody
watching make sure you go to timcast.com
sign up we're gonna have that members
segment coming up hopefully about an
hour or so but you know we have we got a
lot of conversation to be had so maybe
it'll go a little long you'll get a big
bonus episode we had Bannon on the other
day and we went I think a little bit
over an hour yeah so hopefully it's
working I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
it is but sometimes we get weird you
know encoding issues but uh you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast you want
to shout out to Daniel yeah Daniel
Turner and you can follow me at Daniel
Turner PTF for power of the future on
Twitter and same with all the other
profiles and it is always fun to be here
thank you right on man thanks for coming
uh this is Jack wasobi you can follow me
at humanevents.com you can also read my
stuff in the halls of the US Congress
where they're going to be going over it
and releasing it uh from Nancy Pelosi to
uh bring Johnson and the rest of this no
but um yeah uh we're gonna fight back
we're going to take a stand we're not
complying with this whatsoever like I
said I've been to gitmo Once semi again
I don't care on the other side but when
I go again
this time around I'm gonna make sure to
get the best night's sleep in the whole
wide world because I will be bringing my
my pillow along with would they allow
that
I smuggle it in I'll get it you should
you wouldn't believe the stuff that got
smuggled in a gimmo that's crazy you
have a promo code in case people want to
buy it's promo code so yeah promo code
postal I bought a bunch of towels
because we need we needed a bunch of
towels because we have uh the sauna we
have you know a lot of people who are a
couple dozen people here uh I think I
ordered like 20 towels excellent perks
have they come oh yeah yeah they're
fantastic oh because I actually somebody
was telling me I just got in the
comments that they had ordered some
towels and they were having um they
hadn't come yet big old box came and
okay okay good uh thanks for coming guys
this Alaska thing was really eye-opening
that was really interesting to kind of
visualize I knew you would be into that
so cool I could see what you were seeing
how you were describing it it was very
very enlightening I think it's
particularly relevant for Ian because
his nickname is Ian old Australia the
destroyer of worlds oh yeah come get you
and come and get me Crossland so any any
conversation about the destruction of
the plan in any capacity I think I think
this is the next hour isn't it
and there's a huge graphite Mine in
Alaska graphite one that they're still
trying trying to open as well yes huge
graphite it's going to move to us I
thought about moving there I just like I
like the hot weather is it really cold
it's Alaska man
on the North Slope it was 38 degrees
Yeah I need this hot sun
thanks Ian Crossland check it out but
they do have volcanoes that's hot you
just hang out of the volcanoes
the old the old-fashioned way the old
old-fashioned way too hot and we could
stick a giant needle into the side of
the volcanoes and sieve it out we'd get
all that geothermal heat they were like
oh my God what's going on it's Ian he's
over here
you'll be like that you'll be like that
that last guy in Pompeii get me some
yeah and you guys may also follow me on
Twitter at Sour Patch Lids I just wanted
to say on the topic of life being hard
we fail to recognize that the world is a
very very hard place violence is the
norm poverty is the norm we are
incredibly blessed we've been living in
a bubble for years now our parents lived
in a bubble our grandparents even did to
some extent it's about to get hard and
I'm a little concerned how we're going
to respond to that but I think that
we'll rise of the occasion let's see
what happens
all right everybody we'll see you over
at timcast.com for the members segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys